[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes sir
what's going on realm
the lord's day we'll be back
i see some people in the gerald mack
fresh and early lord of the realm i've
seen this video always love brothers
salute to you happy mother's day you
know me to the matriarchs and everything
shout out to the lord my lords again
with that next finest
editor chief wayne heck is in a building
salute
stern ritter novad no doubts a little
tool man what's going on necromancy
what's going on phantom knife what's
going on my levels
my levels are good
turn my mic up my levels
yeah the atomic sands was going on chaos
mike was going on
senpai kaiju what's going on cliff
do something for your baby mommy
that's what this day me to me
do something for your baby
i like that he broke it down
salute everybody in the realm attic in
the ground talk to him right quick mic
check
what's going on guys what's going on got
it going through a little bit you know
what i'm saying solve we don't know yet
that's probably no solve again i know
the super chats i know
but uh we will try to do our best we got
math in the building pulling up fun
speculations on it's gonna be a fun show
again appreciate y'all we know this
mother's day so we know people out there
with the moms you know
he said ashram said happy men's day the
og mothers yo y'all cray you crap i'm
not even saying that hashtag you wow
[Music]
commander radimus bottom is problem in
the building here's the ashram
curious no doubt shout out to facebook
daniel mcgee what's up iron laws i see
you on facebook we already know yeah
it's another beautiful day so look we
will get
mr mavs the math
it's like speculation in the realm king
will be pulling up no sub we'll not have
somebody pull up later so we'll see
what's going on and a fun show so
oh what's up now i'm omar what's up
what's good uh happy mother's day to
everybody so yeah we will speak to y'all
in a minute we're gonna get mad
talk to y'all
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love
[Music]
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tiller uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you oughta messed up and turned me
to an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm
[Music]
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on
[Music]
that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the snapple and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with the gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just
[Music]
don't stop
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample
[Music]
[Music]
i'm very spoiled but i'm gonna be your
dog thing very loyal but i ain't gonna
hold you i ain't here to boy you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turn me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
wanna compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's sourcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line y'all this is
that standard this is what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to
advancedgg.com use code iron lord on the
checkout this is something i use all the
time got to support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast
peace
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
watch them eat snacks in the attic i
wanted to chill with the pack and be
like a young wolf but then they would
mistake me for attic if i can imagine
it's cool to give you some advice and
invite your girl to your squadron cause
if you don't give her that option you're
gonna be single player like siren you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny worked a
cognito who cares if you fly if you're
still a mosquito you swearing away
something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do that it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right mike check my check make sure
the levels is good
yeah i see levels i see levels
exactly
yeah we good here you hear ye and we are
live happy matriarchs day and salute to
all the great mothers in the realm and
also welcome to the ielts podcast llc
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 256 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm very
excited about our special guest and
we've got embracer group acquiring
square studios
summer game fest 2022
and fury dlc to discuss so we're gonna
get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only a true student of our games
industry but whose unique combination of
informative podcasting dedicated live
streaming and passion for pop culture
easily makes his platform a fun watch
from the am to the pm
introducing the creator of the fun
speculation youtube channel host of the
xbox ultimate fun pop fsp and pm to the
pm podcast
the lord of games movies and comics
whose recent born day was properly
celebrated with halo streams and elf
phoenix mexicano
live from the dallas area and making his
debut into the realm of the lord
my man lord matt aka fun speculation how
we doing sir
hey i'm doing great man that was
fantastic you know i gave pong a little
uh crap the other day because he was
doing some of our guests on pm and the
pm like cog style intros and then he
goes and introduces me because he's the
host of pim in the pm and he's like and
here's mav
they say that to me they say that to me
they do that to me
so i had to get
it's definitely like you know there's a
there's a
an art there's an art to it i believe
you know you put in your work you like
you actually do something ahead of time
of course just letting it come off the
top of your head man it's great but
it's it's great to be here i've been
checking out y'all's show for
ever since i kind of started um
content creation on my side right and
always something to like okay these guys
are doing it right you know these guys
are set in an example
um an inspiration you know so it's kind
of surreal being here now after seeing
you guys and being like wow
because
you guys keep it fun you know there's
we're all gamers right and we all i love
to talk about this stuff we have a
passion for it but you don't lose the
sight of it's video games yes right and
it's all about having fun and and having
great discussions with friends right so
that's what it's all about and i'm i'm
excited to be here and have a great show
man oh that's love brother thank you
thank you man it means a lot and um like
i said for us it's one of those things
that it's kind of sobering sometimes
king i don't know how you feel about it
but like when you hear someone says yo
when i first started i was listening to
you guys and it put your perspective
we've been doing it for a little bit now
because i still feel new
it don't matter did that look like an
iop beanie no it died i got the iop
there you go there you go there you go
there you go
i'm done with you it is very very
dominican oh moving on well say shout
out to mab um first of all what you've
been playing sir what's been going on
with you
this and that i played uh trucked to
yomi yesterday and it was kicking my
butt for real
i i made the mistake of starting it on
hard mode because the descriptions that
they had was like okay you know this is
like just the story and then the normals
like you know for gamers that just want
to kind of get through it and then i and
then the hard mode was like you know uh
for for gamers who like a challenge you
know you just see this all the time i'm
like okay that's the one i'm gonna go
with
they were not kidding dude um on the
challenge aspect because i've probably
died like 50 times already
eldering
i can't really get into the souls games
too much like elden ring is is like my
favorite one probably so far yeah me too
but
man some something about that game's i
think because of like the uh
aesthetic of it and the style of it it
it keeps me like
wanting to go feel back to it yeah
that's the one i keep going i keep going
you know no
yeah it's it's a good game other than
that just halo as always
playing the two new maps
wait hold on
that's a new contest sir mav it's one
new map unless you play both modes
well all my challenges are in last man's
standards like i gotta keep doing that
are you implied that you are not happy
they gave with just one map they gave
him a bunch of macaroni and cheese he
did one
no they gave me macaroni they didn't
give him cheese they gave him macaroni
i've been a defender of halo infinite
talk about it for a lot you know when
they announced the six six-month season
i kind of lost it a little bit as far as
like the yeah the defense you know i i'm
i ultimately it's going to be a great
game i mean it is a great game at its
course but it's going back in that
pipeline of content
season three i guess is where it's going
to be really find its footing it's going
to really convince you
it's going to be a long thing it's going
to be a long six months it's going to be
a long six months yeah i think that's
the biggest launch then i think that's
the biggest problem is the six months
like that's nice
man if they don't got no timeline it's
infinite yeah
i think maybe they're just trying to be
in line with a real launch
around the same time as the ps5 with the
real launch you know what i mean like
just to kind of compete back and forth
you know playstation finally get their
stuff together on their console side and
become available and then halo gets
their stuff together right so i think
the game you know got delayed six months
when it was really supposed to come out
yeah it's a tough one man it's just
shout out to slobo you have to at the
end of the day like you know there's a
lot of stuff going behind that i
personally feel
the studio
just got so far behind and just
production in general and we're seeing
that and not to mention kovid we're
seeing all of those variables come up
at the same time and that's you know
they're like look like don't pop in
there you know kiss me hit me up and ask
you want to play hey well i'd have no
problem jumping in there right but it's
just like
besides halo's gameplay is still oh yeah
fantastic
but
you got to give me something to do with
the gameplay yeah that was literally the
same thing i was like man like when i
jumped in there i'm like all right this
is cool
but i'm like damn six months of of
justice and i know they're gonna do the
paw drops and i know but i'm with you
man but it's like damn we do need some
more they need to
do
what
destiny does with the road map
like the in detail road map like because
i feel like that's the biggest thing
like
it's been like six months since launch
hasn't there yeah these news me
comparing
a 10 year old game no no
no we're not starting dessert we're not
even comparing the game we're comparing
how they show your road maps
okay they ain't showing you nothing for
six months
destiny parked up a road map that said
that had two things one map two map you
would be upset oh yeah for sure but
maybe maybe that's why there's no wrong
oh no
maybe because maybe that's why because
it would it would the visual would not
be
aesthetically appealing
i think destiny would be okay with two
new pvp batteries
remember back in the day we had the same
issue with destiny yes
absolutely so you know it's like all
these games like kind of go through this
now halo's going through a little bit
worse than some of them but especially
with how big a budget is i got too many
games to be carried
that's the thing it's like it's
with with xbox though it's going to
become less and less necessary like to
where we're having to focus on halo
right right because there's going to be
so much stuff coming so the next six
months are gonna be fine regardless it's
not like i'm gonna be like oh man
there's nothing they play no doubt
here's the thing the game the game's not
going nowhere you know maybe infinite
that's in six months they'll be able to
you know really fine-tune the game to
where it should be
that's the same kind of energy i give
destiny i'm not trying to play destiny
full-time i'm not trying to play halo
full-time give me something to come in
there and do and then leave like i want
in the front door
play the game i want to go out the back
door like you're almost in the same
motion
they just they just risk the losing of
the zeitgeist
with it
right
this just plain elder brain coming right
i'll see you later like see you later
anyway the rebels are saying time on
this they like time get over here like
why are we doing the halo expo that's
cute they can tom they don't get they
they don't get a tom us oh damn oh
okay he gonna fight back on halo
i got nothing against the game it's just
like we can all agree that you know as
far as conte it does need to get better
yeah
get the super chats queued up i'll start
the intros and of course we know we got
the well we don't got the four horsemen
shout out to lord psalm did see him last
night when he was at the doctor strange
drake went on lord lord saw the lord i
mean lord um kai box with lord marlonius
got to watch that but yeah he is still
in move-in season man he's in a holding
pattern sense of love to solve he's not
he's not man
love the box love the box man man he's
in transition with the moving through so
you know it's still a stressful
situation so he will be back once that
is resolved but we still got my co-host
with the cole most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh yeah
so i did something i
haven't done a long time
well actually it wasn't that long ago it
was about two years ago i replayed final
fantasy vii on xbox live
um i beat it on switch i even beat it on
the theater i beat it on uh uh
ps1 ps3 ps2 uh so okay but see i didn't
beat it on the the xbox or just bought
it you know what i'm saying and then i
went on with my life but
i'm sitting there i'm like you know what
let's go ahead and let's let's play this
game so
i that that's what i did i went back and
i started playing uh the game again
and one thing i could say is like
regardless how you feel about what
they've done in the past yeah
it's still such a fun game well i i i'm
still enjoying it
it's it's just one of those things where
it's like
they had
they were so far ahead of them their
time when this first happened
it's just it's fun to just go back and
play you know i got like they they asked
me to do like crazy stuff like get uh
eris's limit break like her final limit
break and for those of you you know
spoiler uh spoiler
15 year old game
she dies so you have to do it before she
gets capped
[Music]
when that happened again
[Laughter]
did it hit did it hit the fields again
it hit like it did back in the 90s
exactly not really
it was a pretty good a pretty good
pretty good example no doubt i am
playing another game uh on the 10th
there should be a review up on this
channel that you're currently watching
uh it isn't game pass that's all i'm
willing to tell you guys
look out for
for that um for that when it shows up no
doubt you already know and of course we
have the incredible hulk of this aka the
access came out
the prophet of xbox that's what i mean
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
be love it lord king how we doing sir
that's when cherry picking going wrong
so i didn't have no cherries today so i
have some strawberries you know me and
canelo doing the same thing i picked my
opponents
and i hope they can't fight back you
never know this thing might choke me
choke last night
so you picked the wrong one big boy was
too much he thought he was boy
i told dudes uh bibble had a stout
and he did certain things that i didn't
like but i said if he can keep his jab
pumping up all night i can see a 12
rounds uh decision split decision be
honest with you and he definitely got
that straight decision
he beat the brakes off canelo yesterday
oh and canelo should have fought
benavidez or fort de charlo
he had a deal on the table for 115 uh
million to fight errol spence and charlo
in two fights he chose to fight bevel
and gennady golovkin and uh again
easiest road is not always the easiest
road brother yeah if you want to dare to
be great you're gonna have to you know
face that fake you can't run from these
men so now you made a built-in excuse
because he's a bigger man that's why i
lost today he was just too heavy for me
because if you would have lost to charlo
or you would have lost to benavidez you
will you lost a man that was your weight
and just had better skills so stop
making up these excuses you're not a
diva you're a fighter get out there and
do your thing but
um we had some passings
uh lately and these these passings
affect
everyone um they affect the people that
love them that they've affected people
that they touched along they pathetic
journey on this earth and
i just want to you know take at least uh
a 10 count um for these two individuals
that pass that's djk slay and kevin
samuels yes untimely deaths uh in both
accounts and my heart goes out to their
families let's just get a 10 count on
them please
no doubt all right thank you um but yeah
uh those people touched people going
through uh k slave personally touched me
when we was doing music and stuff like
that
so uh he's a huge part in hip-hop
culture and it's so sad that he passed
yeah absolutely i'm sorry i'm glad you
said that trucking naomi yes yes yes
what's going on with the game i played
it yesterday i wasn't crazy like man
because i like to get in and get out
yeah so i put my joint on normal and i i
went through i made it i made it pretty
far it's
it felt like um what it feel like going
on swordsman
uh it felt like those old samurai
japanese uh samurai films that you will
catch at night
it's it's a really good game it does
have a couple of issues and you know i
wish it would have been a locks uh a 30
or a lock 60. you see some dips there
but this is made by two people uh we saw
this uh when we did the at pax we did
the interviews at pax we have the
interview up
um and we have the game play so go check
that out at loads of gaming.net yeah
you've heard that information out to
people way before
but it's inside game class day and date
and um goshishima take that oh stop
we're not doing that we're not getting
it i'm doing it on
this i'm doing it dude
he's stupid but elder ring been playing
elden ring
um
oh um bug snacks
oh your appreciation has risen
i appreciate the fact that no money down
what's up
my daughter loves that game man
seriously though yeah it's crazy right
who would have known right
i know i never would have bought it you
know never and yeah
but i got her to try it and she
absolutely loves it
it's crazy though because she doesn't
usually play like single-player games
you know she only plays like roblox
minecraft
actually like that grabbed her and she
like just sat there and couldn't stop
you know
she tried greatness it was greatness
yeah
you know and we getting all that
greatness
i'm about to go play some baseball too
that day once we outside
you're ridiculously
so we got a two dollar super chat from
gamer by choice
carl's new name is cog diesel pushing
that power
yo 20 y'all 20 get that straw abandoned
right now you know what i'm saying we
got that 20 off mother day special you
know what i'm saying advanced gg.com put
it cold order to check it go get that go
get that right there we got the new
drink you don't like the caffeine we got
the hydration get your mom's focus
we got the hydration for you bro you
know what i'm saying oh you'll be fine
yeah this is the game it's the
electrolytes no sugar you know what i'm
saying
right now man 20 percent oh i called i
know hit hit the link at the top it's
pinned up powder
happy mother's day happy mother's day we
got a a one
year uh uh member chat from the man who
got them horns all right uh
it looks like he's been a member for 23
months
uh interesting fight night called still
moving wait i see
hashtag good powder hashtag my
uncle 20 years
former uh for moving powder
salute
yes oh my uncle got 20 years for me hey
that's his business
put me uh stay strong put the crest in
that chat man for uh wandering dutch
becoming uh
dutch salute to the dutch that's the
homie
then we got a five dollar shipper from
108 dragons salute my brother hey king
how call uh
i'm not
the head banging the head begging old
school rap
from donald taco
we're not even really waiting six months
because ford beta drops in september
which is the really the most important
feature that will eliminate droughts um
i don't really consider a beta being
part of because in my experience betas
don't normally function correctly at
first either
but who knows we'll see we got five
dollars super drop from italian clouds
all hell king no timeout on king today
babe we need kings
we need that
a service super trap from face shut the
face always messy
xbox live down the whole weekend xcloud
is the future we're going to have to
talk about that you said xbox was that
live was down the hill
it was that was down the whole weekend
where you live my joint was popping i
always wanted to sit down you was good
so it don't matter
we we're really going to have to talk
about that yeah listen i don't know when
he can't talk about that he capping but
he don't talk no actually i don't i
don't really know what you're talking
about oh you don't know we talking about
that oh i seen okay so the only game
that i was playing that was multiplayer
game was elden ring right and i seen the
little blood stains on the floor i sac
summoned people so obviously xbox wasn't
down to me i saw my friends
i was talking to people so obviously
xbox was it did not affect me so i
really can't talk about a situation that
didn't expect me to kind of miss me got
a two dollar super trap from donald
tucker
attic ready uh ready for attic to
butcher some
wow
wow that's messy from
eleon
uh the sunsets upon the darkness peace
the lords of the realm happy mother's
day to the mother oh echelon seven of
them
salute
and then we got fidel scripture from
forza legends thank you marvel for
showing scarlet witch's true power in
this movie good morning
controversial right there
we're going to spoil a 2 super trap from
shrimp kingdom rest in peace kevin yeah
1 000
absolutely then we got a 19 month
message from
suicide kings love and praise to all
those mothers out there that have held
all of us down for the uh for so long
yes uh thank you mom and we got a five
dollar super chat from mr irish
greetings lords just back from seeing
doctor strange it may be let me make
sure this is not a are you good
okay it may not be your favorite solo
mcu movie it's definitely not for
i was just reading to make sure it
didn't have a spoiler in it uh then we
got a 10 month message from bunty
to listen tomorrow while i'm at work but
i'm glad to be here for seven months
great
work iop keep it up enough respect i
appreciate that much love and you you've
been here for more than seven months my
friend you've been here for 10. yo slow
mo you stupid he said addict read these
super chats like floyd mother way mother
you better stop anyway flame fight out
you super change get it get him get him
at it get him
i guess guess what guess what uh
i i see i have power over you
[Laughter]
then we got a five dollar screws right
from flame happy mother's day to halo
limited the mother of all
superb life so far
wow
live service game just kidding tell your
mom you love her today
then we got a 20 a 20 months uh message
from gerald mack
call face moving powder
to be fair you can't really complain how
you be pushing the stuff i'm just
talking about product i don't know
what's the problem with the product
continue
and then we got a 25 month uh
message from elliot
i'm not gonna try to try that
one
a salute to the lords brown and lord mav
always a pleasure to catch the sunday
live show while working overtime can't
wait break it down absolutely no doubt
so kane that's what everything you've
been doing sir
well yeah
all right no doubt shout out to one way
dragon tv five dollar super chat addict
and mav y'all keep talking crazy about
halo i'ma have to put y'all on the same
team and punish both of y'all facts free
smoke let's go
[Laughter]
no that's how you
that's what you need to tell yourself
of course we have
the game religion himself the shouldn't
be lord incognito spreading that
realness to the roman iop not telling
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear shout out to defining duke my
man's maddie plays we had the great fork
and spoon debate we had the spark debate
and now it was to catch up on the eggs
and the macaroni and cheese debate
shooter we also talked about games at
xbox
so salute to that go check that out it's
all live on the last day of media
youtube channel if y'all didn't do the
patreon and then um we also had in on
what you call an ultimate go check that
out up on the patreon really good
discussion shout out to ebonitus thai
guy travis just the homies at the
destiny campfire talking that guardian
games season 17 predictions all that
from me lost
i was trying to play trek to yomi
but i was unable to on two separate
occasions which were the only times i
had to play
yeah when i loaded my single player game
that was offline because of services i
was prompted that i could not play this
then we need to just talk about that
because yes i got a question though did
you buy it or did you play it off a game
pad i played it off a game pass okay
that doesn't matter though no that's
nothing to do no no but i i think i
think attic where where are we going i i
had this discussion with maddie and that
was literally what we were talking about
about the defining ultimate which was
about you know the whole physical games
thing and the only thing i listen i'm
pro digital so this is not a bash on
digital i'm digital all day king knows i
am team lazy i don't like grabbing discs
up i love the digital movement and i was
actually not opposed when xbox one did
it
but yeah my only thing is
for single player games
there has to be some type of thing a
system in place where there's not a
required online check and you can still
play that because i look at a game like
let's be honest halo single player you
can't really do that without the disc is
a glorified drum check let's be honest
and then you know i look at a game like
hitman 3. i took that on the x screen
there's content that's available this
content that's not available and this is
a single player game through and through
so i just hope they come up with a
solution for those type of scenarios
because that's where the physical games
people really you know beat their horns
like yo we have to address this so
that's all i want to say i want to come
at them crazy look out just happen you
know it looks like it is up now or
whatever but it did it was crazy that it
missed me
like it's crazy because i played trekkie
yo i didn't even know like you said
check the yoga i'm like i was playing at
all yesterday i was lit i was really
outside and the sad part about it is
i would think y'all captain if all three
of y'all didn't say it i was just
thinking oh he's just making something
up because his efforts went down over
there squirrel and bit the lines over
there
see what happened to me though david
like um my wife was playing gta online
like all day yesterday and the day
before so it didn't affect her
whatsoever you know but she owns that
game right and then
i played uh some marvel vs capcom
yesterday yeah which i which i own right
and it launched fine okay then i tried
to launch truck to yell me and i got an
error right which is not playing off a
game pass so uh but i saw on twitter
they said hard hard reset yeah
reset it so i reset it then relaunched
it and it and it launched fine yeah that
was that was the user just wasn't
resetting it
here we go that's all it was yeah yeah
okay could have been something to do
with the licensing with the game pass
subscription because you have to be
online for a lot to verify your game
pass description as opposed to if you
own the game then it can do that 24 hour
off you might be on to something man
it might be fake news this might be fake
news shout out to ksrt i own elder ring
and i still couldn't play it shout out
to people i was playing
oh so it doesn't exist got it got it we
put our head down because you didn't
experience it it doesn't you know what
listen
i'm with y'all uh-huh
i got the mean face and i'm the only
dude in the back like this well at the
end of the day
microsoft needs to find a better way of
doing it i don't care if it's even a
multiplayer game that should boot that
should at least boot up to the title
screen tell me you need an internet
connection
like and like look
if you share a digital library you kind
of put it on yourself but i was seeing
people that weren't that don't share
those shares
they have their stuff at home and it was
still messing up and for those people
not for the digital library stuff
because that is a feature that people
have been using differently for years so
you kind of set yourself up to have
issues if something like this were to
occur but for people that hate aren't
doing this and being sincere about where
the home is on their on their platform
it shouldn't do that right it should at
the very least
let you play single-player games like i
said for multiplayer games you should at
least be able to boot them up you should
never have a situation where you can't
at least launch a game yeah no i get you
and we get system outages and issues
that happens you know i'm saying i don't
wanna you know things things are gonna
happen we just gotta come up with
especially with single player games i
feel that's where the owners should be
and hopefully they come with hopefully
this is a wake-up call to come up with a
situation what happened it was like i
ain't had access to my gaming two well
it was literally like a good 15 hours
smooth good play and i was mad hard
resetting everything and i know people
who had the not my home xbox thing did
the reset so look hopefully it's a
learning thing
i'm sure they'll fix it and then they'll
figure out some kind of what's that was
the playstation out this weekend no
was it nintendo out this weekend nothing
i don't know of no okay where are we
going guys that's when you blow the dust
off of those other consoles and then one
console isn't active right now right
over across the street see this is where
it pays to have everything and don't be
sitting there championing a piece of
plastic like oh man you know i can't
we'll just go right across the street
[Music]
you know i mean just to mitigate the
time just to mitigate the time don't get
frustrated don't be going on twitter
going crazy just take your time out just
look at the ready it's a service they're
paying for kids yeah and then actually
your money back for those times
like how we used to do with the cable
bills
issue though because it seems like it
affected everybody differently right
it's not like there was just like here's
this with this one clear issue right
because if you go online even on twitter
it's like i've seen so many people say
yeah i was able to play all my games
fine then you see some say i couldn't
play anything some say i can't play my
backwards compatible game some say they
can't play their game pass games yeah i
don't know if there was something like
that back to the people that you sort of
out of drawing i'm pretty sure that they
could track that part and just you know
follow a little grievance for that joint
because you wasn't able to play your
service yeah you know i don't i don't
even think it's i don't even think it's
that serious because i mean let's be
real here it's not like this happens all
the time i don't think this has happened
in probably a year and a half two years
it's just when situations like this
happen where the service is so
off balance where people
are like the d arm issues are so bad
where people was having a hard time just
even loading into a game like i was
playing final fantasy 7 like it was so
bad i thought my console was bricked
like because when i would load into uh
into the xbox live yesterday morning it
not like nothing was popping up like wow
the
my games and apps was blank
so it's just like that
there needs to be a something to
have a good middle ground and i think
microsoft will get it but it's just like
you got your star wars from my
understanding there's two things going
on one
the rumor that i heard was debunked is
that because you know they got the
fortnight with the cloud streaming and i
opened up a whole uh you know thing so
people thought it was that i was told
that that that's not the case the other
thing too is that you know they have to
come up with a solution for the for the
online mode because a lot of it is in
place to really stop the hackers game a
lot of it is in place to stop the
pirating and stuff like that and we get
that but it just needs to be an offline
solution especially if you already got
the ownership and there's a way you can
check it so hopefully they wonder if
there's a way that they can have it to
where
you know
they can do something manly on their end
to switch it to like a setting to
something going on that's okay switch it
to like standby mode where
it pretty much is like updates all the
xbox would have like a 24-hour like
check-in
that's what it's a that's the way it's
supposed to be yeah so like that so
that's what they have correct but it
wasn't working properly correct correct
so i think there was some kind of issue
with the system
not that they don't have the system in
place it just wasn't working like yeah
complete completely agreement
because that's what i did when i got the
x screen you know what i'm saying
because you can play your digital joints
as long as you don't do the my home
sharing thing and you're in an offline
state you can play your digital joints
for the most part when i was on the
train i was doing was going to pass it
all out offline and then have any
internet connection for the most part so
it can be done it's just something with
the way that outage affected their
system they have to come up with a
workaround
and keep in mind that this will happen
anyway
if the moment you have internet
connection and let's say like you're
moving or something and you're waiting
for that internet like if you share a
digital library you only have access to
what you the person you're sharing with
has bought right
because that's how it works the only way
that you have access to your stuff is if
you're signed in right uh so uh keep in
mind if people that are sharing a
digital library that's the reason a lot
of this is happening what's happening to
people that don't have that don't share
but that's rare
but most the time when stuff like this
is happening if you are sharing a
digital library and you're seeing stuff
like this it's because you have agreed
to let the other person use your license
so that's why they can launch your stuff
yeah and you and you uh you can launch
their stuff yeah because that's how the
digital sharing stuff goes the way you
have access to your stuff is by the
online because there's pretty much
the the xbox reads the uh the license
from two different ways whoever has the
home and when you're actually signed
into your actual gamertag but the
problem is is when you can't
you can't sign in
on a network side it's not reading your
license that why you can't launch the
stuff you bought
the other thing too addict i i uh seen a
lot of people say well i only own one
xbox but you gotta double check because
if you owned an xbox four
and you didn't go change it like yeah
for mom
xbox one x or you traded into xbox one
and you got like a new xbox if you don't
go and actually set that as your home
xbox
it's not going to change automatically
right so that's a good point
are you finished what you're going to
say man no i was just saying you guys
just got to double check that because i
think a lot of people just assume that
it automatically happens because that's
what you play on correct but that's not
the automatic thing
and keep in mind like
even if you have only bought one
console in the past just go make sure
your stuff's home but there's constantly
having glitch especially in the preview
program
so i mean there's constantly being
referral you know that preview program
has told your console this ain't his
home leave
spread misinformation
no no no i'm saying i'm saying that when
you're in like preview programs stuff
stuff like that does happen well yeah
you're more susceptible to bugs or
something because you're yeah you're in
an early yeah so it doesn't hurt that
especially if you're in that preview
program just keep going
just to double check that your console
is set for your home no okay fair enough
for that so now that we've got all the
technical stuff out the way
let's get it close to each other before
we start getting into what we're here
for got a couple joints going in
we have who we got what we got we got i
got them all you gotta get cool get them
kill them up came out
we got a um a 30 month
member ch chat from stitch
everybody out here complaining about
microsoft buying activision why embrace
you is building an empire escaping under
the radar and nobody seems to have an
issue
the reason that is is embrasure is
they're not a platform holder so i think
they see that a little bit differently
uh two dollar superstar from dawn otaku
i couldn't play physical or own games
saturday and we just brought that up
like i said it doesn't happen often but
it is annoying when it does happen we
got two dollar super chat from flame i
was at work during the outage oh well
well lucky you flying
thank you for your sympathy for the rest
of the population we got a 17th month
message from
devi
or duvei i don't know happy mother's day
to all the moms out there i did exactly
what king said it was working at first
and then stopped and went and on my
playstation 5 and played no doubt then
we got it all the super chat from 108 uh
dragon kog is a troy troy
powder powder yeah you cut the reference
shout out to troy you got it yeah only
only brooklyn would know that
we got to find out soup trout from
hollywood
another great sunday great job last
night king loved doctor strange views as
viewed it as one comic issue in the
storyline pipeline don't lose
live update my
new york i guess he said upstate new
york
uh we will be doing like a spoiler cast
on that movie but we don't know when
we're going to do it soft did watch it
with you right yeah yeah we all
everybody so
sometimes when we want to figure out a
good time because uh king and saul uh
not king it's all cog and solve like uh
have weird schedules so we'll have to
figure out what's good for everybody
generally saturday then we got
we got a five dollar super trap from
dead planets
if anyone needs a good laugh please
check out ign's xbox showcase prediction
compulsion at support studio gear six
next from tc
what's tc next from
the coalition the coalition uh plus star
field delay oh i don't like how i'm here
and there i don't know then we got to
fight out of super chat from uh uh duvi
duvey whatever i'm sharing with my son
and i think that's a that's
that's what happened it happened after i
started helping him on eldon ring
no doubt absolutely so we pretty much
caught up for the most part one last
joint for me
want to shout out some merch shout out
anonymous you got the snapback you got
the ilp wall hang but you got to put a
comment when you guys are copying this
uh the swag just make sure you leave a
comment so we can shout you out give you
the problem
thing you know what i'm saying that was
you oh okay that's why i'm taking so
many taking some access glory things
they don't want to say something i'ma
say something that was me that was me
all right that was the whole team in
there you know saying do what we do so
now that we've got the super chats all
that stuff taken care of we got to focus
on lord math his video game system
history his journey into content
creation and of course what led him to
creating the amazing fun speculation
youtube channel so lord mad let's start
from the very beginning man what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming
oh man um so i was born with an
intellivision of the house whoa
okay so listen up
pull out you know the closet hook up to
the big wooden wooden tv in the living
room
and it was one that became a tv stand
years later you know what i mean yes so
we would we would hook that up in the
living room play you know games like
burger time snap wow
astro smash
you know i grew up on that and it was
easy for a kid to play because it had
those like plastic sleeves you know with
the pictures on the buttons right so you
know it was really it was really cool i
was able to get into gaming and it was
like some of my favorite times every
time we played played all those games
right um but then like the first
real console like we got after that like
a new one that we brought into the house
was a sega master system
um it wasn't my choice i probably would
have went with nintendo on design but my
brother was a little older than me so he
got to get what he got maybe that maybe
the match system was a little cheaper
that may be another reason but
i had a blast he was like double dragon
r type two play a double dragon don't
forget double dragon yep double dragon
um there was somebody like space harrier
wow
dude so many great games back in the day
um
and then just always been gaming ever
since dude i mean i i got a snes and uh
64 you know playstation
all that transition from the math system
to what what was the next one because
that was the brother so what was it yeah
it was after that was it nes straight
through because for you or you guys
missed the gym
nine year old birth my nine year old
birthday i got an snes
for my birthday right that was my
request yeah that was the first one that
was like for me for you for you you talk
about what you what games like
oh man
you know i was all over super mario
world
i played through that game probably like
50 times yoshi's debut yoshi's debut
y'all can't remember yeah yo she's there
when she came out that was when mood 7
hit yes continue yeah yeah super mario
world um dude i mean there's so many
games back then there was so much
there's a lot of games on the snes but
that was the first time i started really
kind of getting into rpgs and stuff okay
okay okay
like mother or was it final fantasy
no it was like i think it was like but
it was some final fantasy and there was
also like uh chrono trigger
i do want to point out that you guys
would be proud of me
um my heart was throwing these away
this is the lord right here throwing
those away wow
wait hold on i gotta pin that i gotta
pin that hold on hold on
wow
attic with the oh gee let's go atticus
go
that was the game right there and i
remember blowing those cards
oh gee let's get it
what else we got who is throwing all the
awesome who's throwing these away
my memory sucks i'm remembering a lot of
this stuff there's like there's like 15
more back there and the actual nes it's
oh it's super nes
my aunt was throwing them away wow
absolutely that's crazy
those are gems those are jabs right
there and [ __ ]
she called me and she was like do you
want this suit because she used to she
used to have an obsession with playing
um
dr mario yes and she just i guess she
just it doesn't interest her anymore
because they've had it for years and she
was throwing them out and i was like i i
was there and she's like what do you
want them i was like yeah sure i'll take
the
no
boxes
listen man you stayed uh nintendo
from super nes once you once you got the
taste of defying greatness uh
did you did you stay there or did you uh
fluctuate back
to uh sega in any form because you said
super nintendo then you said uh what was
the nintendo 64. yeah so i went the 64
was the next big one right now that and
the and then the ps1 like the 64 i was
that was hard to get
right like people couldn't get one so um
i got it for christmas uh probably was
like 12 13 or something i still got the
picture you know you know
one of those kids i opened it up i threw
it up in the air it's so stupid i was
like so excited like where you roofed
your system
what was that about
oh my god i freaked out and i threw it
up in the air but i caught it it was
okay
you know i remember playing some of the
uh you know the uh star wars games right
away on that and you know goldeneye was
my jam best music in the history of game
and continue um mario kart 64.
uh i mean so many uh so many great games
on 64. uh and it was like the first dive
into 3d gaming yeah real quick you know
yeah um
with super mario 64 i was like whoa this
is so different this is so nice yeah
analog control moving them in a circle
you know yeah but that controller was
weird man i never knew how to hold it
properly in a better way
hold it like this way for this game hold
it like this way for this game you know
like i think that was the the magic with
the controller that uh mayamato uh gave
us we were able to play it in so many
different forms like if he was playing
blast corpse you just held it in the
middle and had it like a trigger if he
was playing first-person shooter games
you did the same thing when you was
playing mario you had your both hands on
the outside i mean it gave you a lot of
diversity with the controller i thought
it was genius yeah for sure what about
what about them wrestling games man no
wrestling no no oh yeah uh wc wcw versus
nwo nitro
um
oh yeah yeah uh that dude all there was
three of them on the 64. i got each one
i got also going back to the
snes and i forgot to mention this let's
go this was one of the
things that we did the most it was uh
super tech mobile
oh yeah
like that was me and my brother like
every every night
you know going at it on us to protect
yes right
out of the 64 it was like a hindi at
hang time and stuff as well right then
nfl blitz yes um i mean just like midway
games
[Music]
after the 64 you went straight to the
playstation one ps1 and i had the same
experience that my mind was blown
right the first game i played i think
was ridge racer
ridge racer yeah yeah the replays
the music
just like it just grabbed you it's like
different you know like nothing like
that before so let me answer a question
right yeah okay this is a huge question
because it was a big debate and i don't
know if nintendo won this fight or lost
this fight uh
data versus loading times and the
cartridge versus the disc right
yeah how did you feel going straight
from cartridge because you did
back-to-back cartridges super nes uh uh
and then you did
uh nintendo 64.
low times like that instantly into the
game getting to the next scene and now
you jump over the playstation and it
said loading at the bottom when you had
to do your ridge racing it was worth it
when i got into the game yeah you saw
them graphics you saw them grabbing
that ps1 had some of my favorite games
of all time talk to me oh we shared this
tell me tell me why you loved ps5 like i
love final fantasy vii as attic was
saying here earlier yeah
for me though was final fantasy tactics
all attic
that's it go ahead okay
it's a good game tactics is one of my
favorite games of all time bro i almost
like when that because
clearly that that g-force leak is
uh is it's pretty it's pretty accurate
at this point
when they officially announce that
tactics remake i'ma lose it i hope it's
not for like switch or something i like
i don't mind if it comes out for the
switch but i just don't want it to be
nothing but to switch because i want it
to perform good so
it's just like because i played bravery
default that i really realized how bad
it's not covered in hats
because when i played the when i played
bravery default on the switch
it's it's it's pretty it's pretty bad
yeah but it's it's still a good game uh
i i just i want i want to see that game
done in a good way i'll be upset if they
literally just like oh we're gonna we're
gonna splash a little paint on it and
not take a good amount of time with that
game because that game is pretty old so
it's just like okay i felt like that
that kind of grid-based style obviously
you know the original xcoms and stuff
those are there but that game's what
brought me into that genre so that
brought you in to terminate what like
the job system is still better in that
game than any other uh like rpg like
attack i don't know final fantasy v i
thought i had a fantastic job system too
so
so would you love it would you say mav
that because tactics get a lot gets lots
of love from addict would you say that
was your introduction and maybe fell in
love with the genre that style or were
you playing those type of games before
for tactics games for sure right but
like rpgs that was more like came from
the snes and going into the going into
like the uh
um
playstation i didn't play as many rpgs
except for
uh like ocarina of time on the 64. right
right i i i feel like i don't know maybe
that maybe i was missing something but
okay uh the rpg
thing kind of skipped the 64 era for me
you know um as far as the jrpgs and
stuff goes at least
that ps1
i'm i had a my best friend pretty much
lived with me you know what i mean like
he lived down the street but like he was
always at our house
in our house for two weeks at a time
yeah we would just go home and play the
playstation
um and we would go through and rent all
those like i don't even remember a lot
of the names but we would you know go to
blockbuster and just rent these all
these rpgs and stuff and you know play
them over a weekend go and swap it out
play a different one you know swap it
out play a different one
um wild arms wow stuff like that yeah
you know um
i fell in love with the tactics style
and i love the turn-based jrpgs we like
teamed up with strategizing because like
final fantasy 7 and these other final
fantasy games back then like once you
get to those like bosses and stuff you
got to think like moves ahead you know
what i mean like hey do this do this so
we'd have like a strategy guide to find
all the secrets and stuff
the love for playstation one i don't
think it gets enough credit i know the
other playstations are great
what so uh-oh playstation one mm-hmm did
you stay playstation dreamcast baby
cause i was gonna ask you but before you
get into dreamcast
i was gonna what happened i feels like
every time if we say playstation i feel
like you know the moment we say
dreamcast the products just completely
get derailed almost every single time
every single time that we cast low
before we get into the drink i did want
to ask you
eddie asks i mean sega man system and
then snes then you go in n64 and get to
places but i noticed genesis wasn't
there was it because your brother
someone had it or was just like yo i'm
so entrenched in the super nes ecosystem
that was where my heart was
at that point it's more of just like
we could afford like one console gotcha
you know what i mean like i had a single
parent household that's right
and so
for me it was like you got to pick one
yeah decision decisions i i played a lot
of genesis at my friend's house right i
was into sonic and anytime we'd go to
like
target
or you know uh
where walmart wherever they had it yeah
sonic was there i was playing sonic you
know while my mom was shopping
um but yeah i loved i loved i never lost
love for sega didn't not have love for
sega but because decisions and the nes
time came and i was playing all those
nes games at my friends houses oh you
know when it came time to pick the
genesis or the snes i had to have the
snes i respect that i respect that
that's real that's real kane so cause we
got to be real sega fans eddies was
outside like nintendo was the the guy i
got that family calm in the house yeah
oh my god the first time i jumped down
that tube
and he had an echo yeah
i said oh it's over
act for me when they had a live
orchestra on the chip mm-hmm i said
that's it i said oh man second you're
done
i was like
and then that vote seven did the rpgs
and we were like huh
so now we now we fast forward to where
map is at because we made the family
business decision which i respect you
know what i'm saying back in the day
and then now what made you get the
dreamcast because technically like i
said you were you were eddies into play
stage so what was the attraction to the
dreamcast well at this point i had
started making some of my own money
because i had a job you know and
i was always like super into gaming like
you
all the gaming websites i would you know
i would read everything i'd have like
all these uh magazine subscriptions
and
i just i wanted the new thing no matter
what it was you know and the dreamcast
had so many awesome games that were
announced for it dude and i really
wanted to have that sega console
remember i had the bmu you know
that's going to be cool you know i can
look at my plays
right now when we're playing with my
friends and i don't got to worry about
them seeing stop looking at my screen
bro you looking at my plays bro
and then like the fighting games i've
always been somebody who's into lots of
different genres you know so like
fighting games
sports games that's soul calibur though
yes dude soul calibur and soul calibur
soul calibur 2 really is where it hit
right um
people don't remember my favorite game
blue stinger blues blue
i got everything at launch it didn't
even matter what it was just throw it in
the back but that blue stinger it was a
single player over the shoulder
third person player it was it was dope
it was it was sony style
on
xbox one
well it turned into xbox later yeah
continued them three cast stories man
yeah marvel vs capcom 2. oh my god we're
going to take you for a ride
yes sir yeah we man we had like so many
like almost fist fights with me and my
friends over that game
who would you take who was your
character
uh
iron man
uh wolverine barcelona
and uh man i don't even remember that's
like i never had to use the third
character no stars and shapes
i i was going to say captain america but
i feel like the third character i was
kind of like swapped in and out you know
what i mean but i always had to have
iron man and wolverine
you know um
you know i i feel like i swapped the
third one alive like captain america i
did use quite a bit but i never found
that perfect three combo got you but it
always had to be iron man and wolverine
oh
i never had to even switch to my third
character so he was just that nice when
you were just oh okay all right man all
right punching bag a little bit while my
other guys recoup their health
oh okay so he was the test dude
a lot you know just like pick that third
character and block a lot
of the corner just like this i love the
strat i love this chat though
[Music]
yeah but my favorite dreamcast game oh
was tokyo extreme racing yeah wow forgot
about that kid yep
that game was everything it was called
what midnight midnight
something in japan
um
tokyo highway racing i think yeah it was
a different name in japan was it a large
title
on that one i don't know if it was a
launch title it was i mean i don't even
remember who the publisher was maybe hq
tokyo midnight what was it yeah tokyo
extreme race extreme racing
in japan it was something else because i
was buying
uh um imports
so i was not waiting that period of time
so i would get the japanese game and
figure it out when i get to the house so
oh it looked good that game yeah you
went like yeah so the way that game
worked is you would race around the
highways of like tokyo at night
and then you would you would uh have a
car you know you could do some
customization and stuff on it and then
uh you would approach people that are
like you know computer and they all had
a name attached to them right and with a
certain specific car so you would
challenge them you would race them you'd
beat them and then
more difficult challenges would start
showing up until you eventually beat the
boss
oh my god
headlights
you would get challenged and then the
challenge starts off yeah uh the the i
think it was speed king was the was the
boss on that man
like we you have to start developing
strategies like trying to put them into
a wall or put them into like a column
under the overpass to be able to beat it
man but um i love that game there's
actually a sequel that came out on ps2
really uh tokyo extreme racer too but it
wasn't as good interest yeah i've never
heard i was educating me this one kind
of missed my my radar here salute yeah
jake has had some some joints in the cut
man
did you ever before we move on from
dreamcast did you ever try um
shenmue
yeah i like shin moo okay you know uh as
one we played like me and my friends was
kind of coming out like hey let's go do
this stupid thing
it always amazes me king to go to the
arcade in [ __ ] to play a game within the
game i was blown away by that i just
thought that was like amazing it was a
little salute to chivalrously to the
legendary suzuki so now you you're in
that dreamcast ecosystem you're rocking
and rolling then what happens the wheels
fell off
[Laughter]
i also had the gamecube but the gamecube
never really clicked for me i kind of
like i i feel like i got it and traded
it in like three times oh damn oh
game 2 for me like i wanted to be into
the games and i played probably more
mario kart on that than anything else
i had that had the first great wireless
controller on it yes
the wave bird waved remembers that yes
i still got that uh so i i did like it
for some things but i could never really
really
really really get into it you wasn't
walking down the street with your little
purple lunchbox lunchbox
going handman's house i got games
remember the discs was like they were
they finally went to disc but they were
so small and proprietary yeah they was
trying to make sure that they didn't get
pirates
[Music]
the star wars was the best yeah that uh
that star wars game that launch title
that was this that was exactly what was
that remember one of the flying ones
yeah it was uh like the x-wing fighter
or something like that it was it was one
of the best games whatever it's a little
silicon into the game it's funny i mean
you share that before i just couldn't
connect with it like everyone else did
so i was in that same boat while i had
it because i thought as a game i should
have it but i didn't have too many games
and i was like oh right yes
the only mario game i never played was
mario sunshine oh it came out with wind
waker i was like oh no
really i got i got to respect they
hustle son i don't care what's going on
in those little discs no doubt so then
from there what are we doing yeah ps2
and you know a dreamcast really like you
know the 2k sports games came out on
there right and then so i started
playing a little bit online on the
dreamcast for the first time mm-hmm
and the ps2 i got the network adapter
for it as well right
um so i was able to play a sports games
online on there as well
um
you know just played every like that's i
mean that era was like my teenage years
right as well so i was like always out
and about but it when we came home we
always played
different games and you know gta or
um there's just too many days there's
like a thousand games
in the corner with the with the sniper
rifle waiting to see somebody
[Laughter]
mlb the show
i really started getting into it then
but i remember those 989 sports games
nine eight nine
deck
nba shootout was underrated back then
i love you guys hey wait a second three
four three nine eight nine no nine
you're funny yeah daddy nine
okay so i'm one of those people that i'm
gonna go against the noise yes right if
everybody is down for one thing
i'm gonna beat a different dude you know
everybody win adidas i'm gonna go bob
pumas right just like that
and i really did that too that's crazy
so
they it was it was madden it was it was
launch yes
the videos we look at the magazine and
they had madden yeah
versus game day game day
and i ran out and brought that game day
i was so mad because that's the year
madden had the real oh
the whole with the with the hollow eyes
but that was like a
in front of the sony style store in new
york city
the line was wrapped around on the floor
on the concrete and what
if you really think about that's really
torture what they did because
it's like a midnight launch but they're
literally we're looking at a glass
screen where you could see they had the
ps2 on replay and it would just be the
banning and whatever other launch game
and we're sitting there salivating
knowing we got like six to eight more
hours to wait on this live before we
could get on consoles and that console
was very hard to find especially in new
york city
my dumb behind thought that uh game day
was gonna beat matters well i had to
finally concede but i had to be
ridiculed
i don't know how long math that every
time i come in the house they go yeah
we didn't like
[Laughter]
that was another era of like our great
rpgs as well but they had also had like
20 different fighting games that came
out like random stuff you know like it
was just
so many so many different games man like
um so it's hard to like just pick some
but gran turismo i was really bad i was
really into gran turismo back in the day
the phone was realistic
[Music]
i was a game changer yeah grand truth
was a game changer it was all those cars
the simulations yeah real cars and then
seeing again those replay like how you
talked about ridge racer
like that you had to like blink your
eyes like yo that looked real like it
looked crazy like we never seen anything
like that they were taking those real
professional shots and then they turned
the corner and it was it was different
man for sure i remember like the grind
aspect of it too that i like expecting
yeah like you had to buy your first car
you had to buy was like a nissan silvia
or the 840 sx that had like 100 000
miles on it you had three thousand
dollars
and then you had to get its oil changed
you had to replace its muffler you had
it yeah you know you had to fix it up
and then eventually yeah eventually you
could win a race right and then you
could win a race and you got enough
money you built up enough time then you
could sell that car
and buy another car and then it's like
oh man but i'm really attached yeah but
and now if you know what i mean no
you're absolutely right and that's why i
always get grand threesome as follows
initially for how they change simulation
razor because that was the game that
really made me a better driver remember
getting those licenses getting the a on
them licenses was very difficult back
then you had you earned that like you
you were like i'm professional driving
with this one salute
and i showed that to the walls
with the three pedals you were
definitely
yeah oh yeah you said the wolves shout
out to the walls for always being there
for me you know to get by my phone to
get through it you're doing a little
bubble guys
for the real driving simulator that's
the only one thing and then you could
you could just like bounce off those
walls
um but then yeah dude like then my
friends brought over an xbox after it
came out i wasn't like excited for xbox
like i wasn't really on my radar you
know i was like
was this i was probably like 18 years
old you know uh something like that and
i was at my grandparents house and i
heard my older cousins like husbands
talking about it and i was like okay
okay like these guys aren't even i don't
even think these guys play games where
are they talking about this game called
halo like
okay and i had kind of dabbled in pc
gaming a little bit around that time too
it was like i was really the neverwinter
knights and commanding conquerors
stuff right yes um
but you know my uh
my friends like they had got an xbox and
they've been playing halo a lot they
brought it over
i played halo
we played with like that four player you
know uh multiplayer on on the
you know hang them high and all that
stuff no let's go
life was changed that's it from that
moment
you took your playstation to the store
it was like bye
[Laughter]
no no seriously like the next day i went
and took that to this where are you
going
what
you go over there
you see that halo you hear that music
though yeah the gregorian city i had to
have it dude i didn't have enough money
to go buy one out right but i i didn't
have a playstation 2 in about 20 games
and i could go to the game
[Music]
he walked in the house it was like
yes
it's so funny as gamers when you see the
next-gen thing that truly is
transformative and you don't have the
money so you go home and you really
evaluate all the things that you know
you love in this house but what has to
go
gotta go
100 man it's like okay what's worth more
to me i understand i'm not getting the
best value for this but is it worth more
to me to play that one game on that
other system was it worth me to play all
this other stuff i've been playing and i
was like taking it i traded it all in i
got 20 cents for some games i wasn't
even paying attention i don't care all i
knew is i was walking out of that store
and you you know
when you go over all your games
and you have that double check you're
like do i really need to play this
we know we love those games
but the new thing is so powerful that we
betray all of it and we we know what
that was said is so accurate because we
wouldn't know i knew he did that you you
called it you called it and you called
it
simple fact i had that same thing
happened to myself
like i'm not one of those people i'm not
even gonna sit there and cap like a lot
of you dudes be out there i'm collecting
hardware good on you um
if i ain't playing you you out the door
if y'all not in the same generation like
i'm not doing that carrying a
playstation 4 and xbox one into the next
generation you gone son like soon as i
get in the house the next stuff is
outside it's coming outside it is no
debate there's no conversation y'all are
out of here you're not producing new
better greater is outside so
i knew man went in the house and it
really wasn't a debate he had one tear
it was like junior tell your mom's ain't
coming home
i gotta ask
you say some real stuff right here
because
you're sitting there now you taking all
your old beloved stuff
and then you're seeing them tally up and
we know damn well the value is does not
equate to how much you paid but all it's
about
is getting over the price finish line
he's like okay so all this is enough so
i can get this actually yeah like
digging through my closet do i have like
an old memory card from the ps1 how much
will it give me for that you know what i
mean
like what do i have that i can get some
money for to keep this thing you know
what's funny the reason gamestop is in
the situation they're at because they
have the same mindset they did back then
it's like no no no no like evolving okay
people are starting to go digital what
can we do their mind sits like okay
people are going digital how much more
can we get from them like
it's it's so funny the culture we let
you out the pixel veggie like we were
literally getting ripped off but we did
not care as long as we could leave with
it right now
my explanation was if i knew i was
getting ripped off it was okay yes yeah
we we got we got 485 hit the like yo
let's hit that like button share that
i'll get some friends in here let's tell
you about this conversation because matt
was just right here he he went inside
the house and portrayed everything that
he loved
yeah i put it i put it in like
grocery bags you know like plastic
grocery bags
i got like i got like two bags with like
10 playstation games you know what you
know like tie it at the top you don't
fall out in the car yo man you that dude
that used to annoy me when you go to gay
stuff because you know you behind that
dude and he he put all his stuff on the
table and you know the registered dude
will take mad long to add all this stuff
and i'm like if i saw i was cool though
if i saw other people in the store like
you might want to go oh you was good you
was cool with it okay
yeah i mean you want to go first i came
in there with two duffel bags
yo yo
it was two like you could put bodies in
i had duffel bags that you could put
shack in
right so i had two duffel bags of shack
right i had two shots and i walked in
and this is when games this is when i
got my revenge on gamestop this is when
they was taking dvds
for cats right oh yes i remember that
yeah
i shut it down that same day
remember when gamestop had that nintendo
promotion
and it was so bad that that gamestop had
to shut up shut it down they knew when
they messed up they gave us too much
credit
yeah it would no it because because the
the switch games
it might not have it might have been
before the switch i'm pretty sure it was
the switch but it was so
crazy you could go to walmart
buy three switch games of that list
bring it back to gamestop and by the
time they added the cr traded in value
and they added everything you're making
more money than you did spending 200
buying the games at walmart
yeah for the nintendo stuff
gamestop usually has a mess up and
there's always some weight that was a
real mess up but yeah yeah
i think i saw people like ran paying off
like whole consoles with it remember
oh yeah oh yeah it was because it was
only a trade value you couldn't get it
in cash yeah they wouldn't give me the
cash your trade value was super list so
continue back you bring it all up you
got you you know you if you did it at
the right time too you got like an extra
percentage yeah
oh yeah like it was like i've probably
got like 500 something bucks or
something for that all that stuff you
know but then like so i got xbox i got a
few games hey you know halo and uh
project gotham racing
let's go um i can't remember what
fighting games you know
i remember getting when ninja gaiden
came out
oh my gosh
yeah there was so many great xbox games
dude and it was transformative at that
time because like a ps2 to an xbox felt
like a it was a graphical jump oh yeah
people don't people sleep on the xbox it
was a graphical jump because they was
doing rgb
and then we was kind of introducing
hd gaming even on a 720 level the hard
drive the custom soundtracks it was a
lot going on and ethernet x you had like
xbox live wasn't out yet right right but
you had the promise of that coming and
you had the ethernet port in it and i
remember like okay i got broadband i'm
ready i'm ready for this you know
um and when halo 2 came out
that that was that was you talk about
life changer right with the xbox yes
when halo 2 came out that was the real
deal that's when it became like another
level yeah right
exactly i think on two
that's when they were really pushing
that envelope to do welding to do it
well this is
isn't that the one where we had to play
the arbiter
mm-hmm yeah
for multiplayer what blew me away math
was um
i remember being in there
on xbox live right
you're playing it because before it was
kind of like yo you only could play
local and then you both playing this
unless you rigged it with like uh with
uh you know routers and stuff yeah yeah
sure like log into like xp connect yes
we did that too back then absolutely but
it's like i remember being in there and
being in a room
and hearing proximity chat in a game for
the first time
and i was blowing well when you get that
hand around
that arm around that neck and you get it
you get like five seconds to talk crap
however you want you know what i mean oh
my god the splinter cell was wild wild
west and that was the best thing that
was doing that spies versus burke's yes
yes
talk that time
so hey
this one dude grab my neck
and he said
i know you like chicken and watermelon
yo
what you have to waste
[Laughter]
before integrity rules are in place you
had that you had them call of duty rooms
and search and destroy at the post match
oh yeah oh boy don't lose don't lose
ghost recon
bro you would hear all types of joint in
them them ropes they told me he said you
eat your fried rat with your crack
wow because i was from new york he's
like i know you from new york and
beating fried rack and smoked correctly
it was so bad like
dude like because you you doubt you're
introduced to a whole gamer set from
different regions different accents
different countries and that's when the
toxicities
i don't care i don't care how
how how you were i mean at the end of
the day
it's who you exposed to right now if
you're not exposed to a certain
demographic of individuals when you come
across from us as individuals as humans
we are we try to destroy what we don't
know what we don't understand right and
then you find out oh he don't break he
don't fall i like him you always in his
room
i don't know if they was from a certain
group of people that was terrorizing
other groups but
they accepted me right
[Laughter]
they accepted me into that group
and
those were some of the best friends that
i had because i would call them like you
know what you're playing right now all
right let's all group up let's get
together hey man king david coming
through man this is my man king david
and it's so dope that
he he was i got a black friend like and
it meant something it really did mean
something to him so it was just like
xbox was breaking barriers for me
because i met remember that one dude
that was in africa when we turned on our
xbox that night yeah i remember it was
one person in africa playing i said he
must be rich as hell
yo
yo
kick stop i'm just
it was just one you saw everybody across
the world and it was just one it was
just not africa and i was like wow
he must got wild bread
because everybody else was yeah for sure
continue back he's right though man
because like i remember like playing
with people from around the world my
mind being blown yeah you know like uh
halo against people from japan you know
forza motorsport with people from the uk
you know um
all of that and it was like wow this is
like a bigger you know it kind of opened
up your world because you're actually
having verbal communication with all
these people right and it was like wow
okay this is pretty cool and i always
loved the social aspect of gaming even
when i was before
uh playing single-player games and stuff
but like i always played like with my
brother my friend watching you know and
or going to the arcade and we'd talk
about it you know so or talk about even
just talking about the games that you
just played there's always like a social
absolutely so multiplayer gaming when it
came online like that
it just changed everything for me you
know um halo 2 with and halo 2 was the
first one that had like matchmaking
really yeah you know absolutely um you
know he and he's
the guy that invented that has had a
certain affinity yeah right yep uh now
they're you know making that new mode
for halo infinite so matt shout out to
max hoberman shout out to max over nah
man you're absolutely right and i think
that's what you know people don't
realize and there's a lot of people that
don't understand why
some people are in love or ourselves are
in love with the xbox ecosystem it's
because if you are a person who likes
co-op multiplayer games if you like you
like the social aspect of gaming they
pioneered the space and everything you
said was why i fell in love with the
ecosystem it was kind of like oh wow
like i'm hearing i'm outside of my
bubble for the first time there's a
whole world out there that i don't even
know about and then you meet and then
the coolest thing is when you have the
positive
experience
and you like yo you add a person to your
friends list for the first time you're
like yo what she gave it to you adam and
then that's your man there's people that
you become my favorite friends pop up
yeah let me invite you to the party yes
okay is it just me thomas let's go let's
just just talk amongst us friends let's
go
ain't nobody else yeah no one's
listening you feel away
when somebody pop online and they'll
send you a party invite
i was like is there something wrong with
me
i'm like i see them in the group with
people
what's going on that was the way it was
back then because yeah like now now it's
like there's like 200 people online it
seems like yeah it's so bad like back
then you had like your group friends
right you had like three or four yeah
and shout out to all of them i i still
have friends that i met playing halo 2
like
you know the first month from way back
my friends today and like we all have
kids now we're all married now
you know
like no it's dope but then we're just
like 20 year old losers that just like
hung out in our mom's house you know
like before you go inside a room there's
no kids running around you're just
talking now you go inside the room and
be like your tummy get the dishes
[Laughter]
over there it's real man it's real so
yeah you stay you rock with that i'm
assuming then transitions we gotta you
got you ready to 360. i'm pursuing 360
but i never lost my love for playstation
so like i ended up getting a ps2 again
oh right nice um yeah down the line when
it was cheaper and then i got a uh
360
you know one of the best
um
consoles as far as games go uh
i got i got that as well i paid the
1900 it took to get one
[Laughter]
it was like seven it was like 700 bucks
or whatever yeah it was real how much
was it um i got that but i
once that happened you know i
playstation became a place to play
specific games yes yeah for me and xbox
is when i got home
that's what i turned on first right
um and then even with the xbox one
generation that was like really
down like it was still my primary on
this place
yeah yeah there's all my friends all my
friends are there you know like i got
this whole social thing going with
everybody of course
playing everything and then you know oh
this new game came out i'm going to go
play it on the playstation you play it
you're done with it then you go back to
the you got it that was your probably
kind of what it's that's what's always
kind of been for me since then no i feel
like um
yeah dude tremendous series x though
gonna be the best xbox generation i feel
like i don't know it's i think it's head
that way look it's got a tremendous
potential you know a lot of people are
saying the same things and the arc is is
good and we just like i said what
they're doing now is pretty impressive
and obviously we know the the first part
of the situation but yeah man tremendous
tremendous game history we could talk
about stories for for really lovable we
got to get into the content creation
aspect of what you do so now you know
doing all this gaming you got everything
so it's like what inspired you now to
say okay i want to get into
concentration i want to make a youtube
channel
so i always wanted to do something like
um but it used to be sports i used to
want to do like sports radio or
something like that i don't really have
the voice for that you know you hear
these guys like on on the radio you know
they sound like bonds yeah yeah
definitely you know
they sound like that it's like oh my god
you know but i
always was a super geek into sports just
as much as i am with uh gaming but
gaming's always been my number one
passion right
um
but whenever i'm in front of a camera or
um
people i don't know i would just shut
down family and friends i was always one
way in front of a camera in front of
people i don't know i would shut down so
i was like i was afraid to take that
step i'll see you uh
like a lot of people have heard their
stories you know covet happened you know
we look
less sports to watch less shows
yeah i started watching youtube and i'd
always been a fan of a lot of these
podcasts but like the only ones that
were mainstream like i've been you know
like unlocked
gamertag radio
oh allies and a lot
and i loved a lot of those shows um
but
i didn't discover like i i remember
sitting in there and hanging out
watching on youtube and
browsing videos because there was
nothing else to do right
and i i discovered a couple different
shows
i was like well these are guys just like
regular people and they actually got an
a a decent audience you know what i mean
so i was like i'm just gonna play around
with it and see if i can do something i
didn't really watch a lot of the shows
but it was a kind of a trigger to me
that you don't have to work for like a
ign right or one of these places or have
the 20-year history that you know danny
pena and
them have you know with with podcasting
so i was like
i'm just gonna start a show
i had a video camera yes
and i uh
had
that that was it i had a video camera
and i had and i had a little i got a
blue yeti yeah you had the yeti i saw it
oh and i uh i did a one i just did one
man show starting out with that's how
xbox ultimate started i just uh
timed it with the clap you know to see
my audio
video right
with the editing and stuff and i uh i
did like 15 episodes that way and then i
started watching more getting involved
with the community
about how amazing this like community is
with the on with with everybody in the
the social realm like you guys and uh um
you know our rdx flute um you know i
mean there's
there's so many freaking great people
out there dude and you'd be surprised
how welcoming people are and how much
they're willing to give you advice for
tips and i just kind of watch everybody
i'm like okay and i get more and more
comfortable all of a sudden when you
start getting people you know commenting
or or leaving
first it's no longer it's no longer like
strangers it's no longer like a camera
it's family and friends yes again no i
want to go then that melts away yes
yeah i want to give your flaws on that
because me and attic always have this
conversation i always feel like you know
because watching your start it's one of
those things where people don't realize
like it like we do this and it's the
laws and it's also we're having fun but
like being by yourself
and turning on a microphone
and a camera
by yourself and just running through a
show is very difficult absolute recipes
to um to cal he was one of those you
know it's a skill set not everyone could
do that and then like i said you're you
talked about you know you're you're kind
of reclusive nature you kind of you know
fall back he wasn't that way in front of
a microphone naturally so that takes a
lot and then to get comfortable good at
it
not to mention
it's a skill that i do feel like
everybody can get
but it's a skill that people have to
feel comfortable to get yeah and i don't
think
there is a huge barrier a lot of people
don't want people to go on the internet
and talk to other people much less go on
the internet and talk by themselves and
the camera on with it when he's doing
this by itself
i'm saying that's another thing let's be
real you know in no disrespect to
anybody but it's like you know there's a
bit of a safety right king always gets
us into that like you know people want
to see your face so i'm watching you and
i'm like yo his first episode of xbox
ultimate is him by himself in front of a
camera with a yeti talking topics that
that's a skill set not everyone can do
that you know what i'm saying and salute
to you for sticking with it man that
that is that
i had to retake that like it's the thing
when you're doing
you're like for yourself for the first
time you know you start if you stumble
if you're not alive it's awkward you
know and i didn't know really how to
edit too much back then so i would
literally be like 20 minutes into a show
and like
you know i would go and redo it so like
a 45 minute to hour thing was what i was
doing then would take me like eight
hours to try and try and do and what i
that's how it started it man
what i would do to help
like with that because i i was trying
the streaming thing but i realized that
streaming is different than podcasting
it's it takes some print same principles
but it's different things with those and
like what i would do is i would just
play games and just
force my habit of just narrating what's
in my mind
and just interacting with the chat like
that that's that's what streaming's
about and a lot of people when you go on
there you see like people not talking
like that's the perfect way to have
someone in like what is those those
doors that's in big cities the ones that
rotate
that's the perfect way to get people in
that kind of thing like so like i for
like a month straight every time i would
play something i would get my mind in
the habit of just
like navigating and
pretty much narrating everything that
i'm doing and what's funny is my brother
came in he's like what the hell are you
doing i'm like joe don't question it
that's what you do to get ready we'll
get to you man so you're rocking it
rolling and getting into the community
people are taking to you you talking to
people so then so what what goes on then
i started getting asked occasionally to
be a guest on some shows shout out to
gaming beyond the box
i'd only done three episodes so far
right but like people were just so cool
you know they um and if you go back and
watch our first episode of xbox ultimate
at it's not very good you know i tried
my best right now you was holding it
down i was watching it
but about like 15 it was like 15
episodes in people had started like
asking hey are you ever gonna go live
you're gonna do this live right and i
was like
okay i'm just i didn't have any
experience it wasn't cool
the only thing i'd done live was stream
and i had streamed
for the main purpose at that time was
trying to get content up on the channel
yes because i read somewhere that's like
hey if you have a new channel you need
to get as much stuff up as possible
so i was like okay well i can't i'm too
lazy to sit here and make all these dank
videos
so i tried videos it took too long i was
like i'm just gonna stream
hung out with people and it's like okay
i started getting comfortable with being
live as well right that way uh so i was
like okay let's just do it and i i was
like i need to i i need if i'm doing
live i'm not gonna be by myself right
like i gotta have somebody with me
babe
hey my lovely wife you're gonna be my
guest because i didn't wanna i didn't
wanna ask anybody i didn't wanna be shot
down right so
she came on and that was our first live
show it was like episode 16 17. oh
that's what's up that's what's up
and then just kind of built from there
man like yeah bro you've been in our
episode 87 we just hit like
yeah did you had uh you had dirt on i've
seen gregory up in the building yeah
recently look man
we all got to start somewhere and i i
like the journey i like you know also
the varieties that only one you got a
bunch of shows you know you got the fun
pop which is kind of like i'm assuming
like you know pop culture what's going
on marvel dc probably gotta get king on
that one
yeah i could totally see him vibing you
know what i'm saying with that and then
obviously you know on pm to the pm shout
out to laura pong seoul united being and
then fsp so tell me just real briefly
like just the origin i know you said you
want to put more content in the channel
you didn't want to do videos which i
agree with because i'm saying like i
don't like doing videos to take too long
yeah but like what made you say okay now
i'm going to do some kind of different
podcasts and what was this what was the
mindset behind each one well when i
started the channel like that's why i
made the name fun speculation because i
wanted to leave it open-ended to be like
a multiple interest but mostly around
the same realm yeah right and um that
was kind of always the goal
at some point i was going to do
stuff that had to do with other
interests because it's like an outlet
for me yeah you know what i mean it's
like it's like an outlet a fun fun thing
hobby it's all about having fun and
um
so i always planned eventually about
doing like a marvel dc star wars texture
and then then you know it just took him
out meeting the right people you know
and finally like okay let's try this
thing right so each thing was like a
natural progression i feel like it was
never and i was never like months of
planning it was like
now's the time gotcha
so let's just let's just do it
my wife is amazing with
you know graphic
design um art stuff and so she makes all
of our
you know mo uh for the for the
thumbnails for the shows she makes all
that stuff she makes overlays she makes
you know all this stuff for us right wow
and i was like hey we're gonna have to
do another show it's gonna start and uh
next week you know
yes you get it she would get it done you
know um but it took about meeting the
right people like we have an amazing
group of people shout out to the panel
shout out to the panel emily shout them
out
call them fun speculation fan we got you
know psychonauts
mellow fellow pong soul the encyclopedia
gaming dating back to the very first
game ever created everybody knows shout
out to he on every podcast shout out to
paul yeah we got to get fogging around
everybody's uh british mother right um
happy mother's day lupa uh then you got
you know uh three beds
crazy talented uh freaking and insanely
talented i wanna try and make sure i'm
not forgetting we you know we added
jasper on there who's like
talk about skill level in gaming that
dude is insane beast i mean he
he will pour through games like crazy
elden ring in like a day damn
like it's it's crazy dude i mean it was
i mean i'm exaggerating probably
two days but he was that still beating
that's still beast yeah i mean he's
insane um
yeah we got the lady uh af has been a
part of our channel um
fuzzy belvedere oh shout out to fuzzy um
yeah
my wife caitlin of course you better
shout out the wife you didn't go home
yeah we just kind of figured that right
great a great crew that kind of became
family so you know ultimate is a show
where like you know we have a larger
panel and things can go left a little
bit you know we have you know that's
kind of what it evolved to from she put
she put the hard emoji to the chat
you're good you're good you put you
remembered and she put the heart emojis
right in the chat shop the lady caitlin
of the realm salute
um but yeah man it's just uh just grew
to all those amazing people man that's a
key shout out to gaming key out there
he's kind of been on a hiatus stupid
uh he's somebody that's like you know
streams got great setup and everything
and he was hanging out in the chat early
on when i was just like streaming to a
few people you know he was one of the
ones from the beginning yeah but i've
had the pleasure of meeting people like
uconn king david and addict here you
know we've had lots of guests and um on
multiple shows now so it's kind of
growing like how i and i envisioned it
originally it's like kind of like a
network
for fun discussion right that's what it
that's what it's all about love the name
love what you're doing
tremendous work you know i'm saying you
guys are having fun and it's just
growing man it's good to see you your
journey go that way um i definitely want
to shout out you know as far as
respecting the channel and like i love
the aspect it's like you got this kind
of like married power couple it gave me
where it's kind of like like engaged
let's be honest that's rare like a lot
of relationships that kids can attest is
you know
they don't necessarily support
the hardcore aspect but to have
you know
wifey engaged in it you know what i'm
saying like active you talk about like
designing thumbnails doing that you know
i i loved it and i shouted to y'all
watched um you take two uh streams you
guys get together that was that was kind
of funny i was seeing that and uh you
know how cool is it to kind of be part
of like a gaming power couple how does
that feel
yeah i mean it's crazy now she's like
that started you know stepping more into
like other stuff too now she got like a
tick tock going yeah
yeah it is i mean popping there's all
type of stuff going on i'm like damn
talked about that
yeah i mean just like a lot i mean it's
it's awesome to have somebody you can
like go to like hey uh
you know we you got any ideas you know
we can
i do have an overlay you know that i
need you know and she what i loved she
at first when she like was doing the
podcast she wasn't like i don't really
know any of this stuff like she plays
games right but she didn't follow it
like like we do you know what i mean as
far as like all the news and like what
everything means she just like puts the
game in place you know
um but
what what i love that she added to the
show
and the channel like was she kept us all
grounded right
and and then added that other aspect of
like giving me that gave me crap all the
time yeah i almost flipped that i
appreciate it i was just that was that
was professional on the last day we
appreciate that
gave me crap all the time you know what
i mean and like it's just it's just
natural like it's how we are in real
life you know what i mean like yeah we
just how what you see
what you get here
i mean that's just how we are like every
day and it just kind of goes you know
i'm lucky that i have to be a part of
that but also all the other the graphic
design and all that kind of stuff
because i'm not very good at that stuff
you know so
she is so absolutely shitty babe happy
mother's day happy mother's day it's a
little lady caitlin in the realm sitting
up in there she rides she go hard for
that fortnight i see her trying to
convince the whole paddle but salute
is what's up yeah she goes and last
thing i have personally for you so all
right we had our pre
you know nina's cowboy thing earlier but
i gotta ask you lord mav the name is it
strictly
a dallas maverick thing
it is i can give you the origin break it
down like so halo 2 days originally back
back then you remember xbox had three
months trial codes yeah with the games
so my original gamertag was actually
ground control because i played you know
espn nfl 2k5 like crazy right and
um
i was like ranked in the top oh and they
reset the leaderboard yeah that was like
the gold football game salute yeah oh my
gosh it was amazing yeah so
when halo 2 came out like i uh
made my gamertag maverickslayer
right
and then every three months i'd have to
change it because i got a new code and
back then there was no achievements or
anything so you know i didn't really
care right i kind of regret it now
because i would love to see that 20.
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you know but like
i basically when i bought a game that
came with the three-month trial code i
just uh yeah whatever when it ran out i
just made a new gamertag so it was
maverick slayer then it was like
maverick uh maverick slayer two
and then and then that guy people
pop up it's me yeah you be like yo where
are you at
maverick came from the mavericks i'm a
huge mavericks fan like
massive mavericks fan slater became a
slayer team player so uh maverick slayer
and people started calling me mav
naturally over time so all my friends
started calling me mavs so then instead
of you know maverick slayer whatever i
just change it to like map five math six
and then math seven is when they stop
putting those dang codes in the box
so
that's just how that's how it is
working out because seven is like the
number i
wore when i played baseball
and basketball so it kind of doesn't
matter
no doubt okay i got the official that's
what's up that's what's up and of course
the question we ask all in the realm
you're on the spot now
top five video games or franchises of
all time lord
maverick
halo
splinter cell hmm first of all
final fantasy but tactics
oh addict do we approve
tactics
i got a lot of stuff going on oh that's
cool brother that's cool tactics
man how are you gonna get me like that
now is where it gets interesting four's
a motorsport
okay
um and then for the fifth one
is okay
uh i i'm gonna have to be real and say
call of duty
you know what respect respect people be
ashamed and they know damn well they'd
be they were going hard they would call
the dude
yeah like well it is it's lately yeah
like what i'm talking about all the time
for the heart like if hardcore gamers
tend to be ashamed to throw it in
but like oh no no no soon as soon as
activision was required i was call of
duty all day here we go i love it
this last one is the only one i have not
bought okay
okay like i bought every single one i'm
waiting for to come to game pass you
i just don't get the i just i'm just
sick of the like world war ii yeah four
scores what could the game pass do
i played that i played that beta i
played the beta i was excited to play
the bait i played the beta like that's
just not it you know this is like this
is a step step back
game pass when it's freedom
yeah i want the whole catalog
done anyway moving on and follow joy
favorite console of all time and why
um i know
i'm not gonna i'm gonna surprise you
guys though oh probably because i'm
gonna do that televisions oh you gonna
say the series x
series x
break it down because
because man like i've never bought a
console day one and had it improve
everything i already own
oh yeah that's kind of crazy right right
like it you go into like i bought it and
then all of a sudden my games look
better they load up better they you know
the frame rate's better on a lot of them
they added the fps boost and all this
stuff the battery
uh stuff i went back and played so many
like old games and and beat some games
that had just like didn't necessarily
click as much for me before but now they
played in a new way
you know so that plus all the uh i mean
just the game pass effect dude
i've never
been able to like have a console
and play it and just know that there's a
stream of games coming out to me that i
already have are going to have access to
um and then also
just be able to have that libraries yeah
no no that yeah even xbox one when we
moved into xbox one they didn't add that
back compat to later that is true it
wasn't it initially because that was a
big phil thing when he took over he's
like we're going to try and figure this
out yeah right this is the first time
i've ever
bought a brand new generation
and your whole library move with you
pretty good point right point so that's
that's why man cause i got 360 games on
there i got original xbox games on there
i got it so box one games on there i got
i got all these new games coming out all
the time um who did that for you
i was literally about
[Music]
it's changed the way i game too right
because like all these indie games and
stuff that are coming out i never
necessarily would have played those but
now i'm like loving them you know
we're gonna act like jason ron on his tv
listen sir when tom when when when the
patriots go out and win again
tom brady gets the praise right so we're
not gonna shout out the offensive line
we're not gonna shout out to the
receiver listen tom brady
on the field
he's not the only person on the floor he
gotta they gotta hike but
tom the only one that got a ring he's a
team
yes it's a team sir yeah it's a team
sport
and it's a ring and it goes out to the
quarterback
[Laughter]
it's a don matrick for plummeting this
song oh so badly that they had to
rebuild yeah they didn't have to rebuild
i love the trading story that was
brought back a lot of memories oh man oh
man we could talk again with you all day
we still got some show up soon but you
still hanging out in the round rocking
with us how are we doing on time you
okay there sir dude i got all the sunday
man oh eight hour shows
[Laughter]
don't give them any don't give
the chat any ideas
salute man that was what's up tremendous
we got to get into us though uh attic
you got a super chat i got a couple of
super chats queued up if you need i got
them all all right cool let's get the
super chats going right quick
and then i'll do the poll
uh let me bring it up mm-hmm
bring it in so we got a
[Music]
we got oh my god stop going down there
yeah don't you wanna move you got a six
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got a 16 month message from shreem
kingdom
13 months but uh but i've been here
since the before king's ps5 will have a
carter here
thanks for the entertainment
attic don't mess up my milestone chat
you know what man i didn't but i should
have if i read this chat i would have
messed up your name on purpose
uh we got a 10 super chat from uh moz
gaming nice to see math here
super cool dude oh shout out to mods
salute we got a a super trap by the
collector
uh what's the most runes you've lost an
elderly ring 500k here thanks for the
laughs i've lost like 10 million before
you said 500k listen the other day i
lost 2.5 million dollars i screamed like
i lost real 2.5 million dollars and his
dumbest thing is i was fighting this
stupid dragon i said i know where to go
get my rooms
why the dude around the corner normal
sleepy-eyed dudes slumped me i'm too
strong to be getting slumped by the
sleepy i do and i got sleep i got
slumped by the rock because i thought it
was too strong for him you know
i think the most i've lost was like 10.5
million at one time jesus yeah and
what's funny is at that time i was just
getting so many runes
uh i didn't even go back for them
because
then you know what's worse when you when
you lose bruins in a ball stream that
you know you have to beat the balls
together
that's it
elon musk in the pockets
possible takeover
we got to fight out super chat from
drawing tj hi lords hi my uh mav the
best racing games that are now dead are
midnight club project gotham racing and
midnight madness yep
midnight club's coming back though
hopefully
then we got a two dollar super shot from
forza legends
uh
gamecube resident evil 4
had to have it
guys i remember that wasn't that
exclusive at first to the gamecube
wasn't even before
that's a crazy exclusive because a lot
of people consider that the best
resident evil i don't know it was really
good though
oh my god then we got
that you on the show i appreciate it bro
all right then we got a uh two dollars
from uh from duval uh just shy of 500 in
the chat hit that like button then a two
dollar super trap from suicide kings
shout out to the earlier days of gaming
classic and let me double check make
sure that we didn't get anywhere
huh we got a little black dot beeping at
the bottom
okay
we're good we seem to
how we doing slow just make sure he
might check you good
yo what up what up what's up y'all chris
b christmas little slow so we got
no doubt hold on i'm still putting a
request for this camera i'm just
okay
when you follow the complaint
right now
people are coming out of me in the chat
i get that camera we good
you dudes is crazy walking around with
more than 50 000 rooms soon as i get
that i spend it
here's the thing once once you're in the
like the 150s or hundreds mm-hmm you
can't buy a level with that much you
have to have a lot more than that like
you need like a million roons yeah
upgrade yeah and after you have
bought everything that you possibly need
there will be sometimes that like i will
buy stuff just because i know it will go
to my chest like uh the the arrows that
you get from what i would literally buy
like two million worth of that because
once you're on like all these higher new
game pluses you get crazy runes that you
really realistically ain't used
that's why we going to people's room
like you drop me some cash
[Laughter]
what you got on my drink homie
yo
you stupid moving on i'm crying the car
let's get this phone man lastly folks on
the inland people have spoken with
sources hinting at required two hour
game trials by developers for the ps
plus premium service do you feel this is
a pro consumer move by sony the winner
in a three-way iop poll with a
dominating 88
of the vote
no paywall in game demos and making
mandatory requirements of devs is not a
good look when game pass exists
coming in at second place at only six
percent of the vote i don't care i'm
still trying to stack my playstation
plus description vouchers before the
spartacus fed's coming get me
and
it
percent of the vote was yes the ability
to try a demo for every game is just an
additional feature to a service
providing back compat cloud streaming
and discount value
[Music]
okay
you ready to talk how do you feel what
the rail says it's on the premium tier
the premium tier allows you to play
demos
what the hell how is that premium
like if somebody came to you and they
said okay so if you if you buy the club
package uh you get ice cream you're two
dollars you get two two hour demos on
ice cream you're like what's that and
they come and they bring you a little
scoop you know how when you go inside
baskin robbins they give you that little
scoop of ice cream
you got to fake the front with that face
oh delicious that's a demo
in that ice cream we made a boy as we
back with a bait of white tip again
oh man
absolutely disgusting
and i see the narrative and you guys
aren't complaining because you can't
complain you gotta take it first of all
you didn't like streaming but now you're
like streaming with demo
i do have something important i need to
say yes please uh so i did have someone
in my family pass away oh i'm sorry this
um he was actually the dude that
introduced me to battlefield he was the
dude that gave me the room to kill gamer
tag oh that's how i met you bro dude
that's how i know he was unfortunately
he he passed away uh
you know substance abuse finally got to
him and uh i'm gonna put his gofundme
now if you guys uh you know okay
any of you out there that you know you
feel
extra generous you know definitely help
him out you know i i seen him in years
so like
is his name is marty man like he was he
was a good dude
i guess just one of those things where
it's like when you don't see someone for
years you don't really notice like
it's not it doesn't really hit you until
it hits you you know what i'm saying
like it's like i said like i remember
playing battlefield 2 with them uh and
we he came up with room to kill that and
then what's funny is that went from
battlefield 2 on pc to xbox
and then i had that name for like seven
or eight years bro that's when we know
you yeah that's what i know you know and
then i went from uh that to this lord
address with these numbers
it was just like i hated that because i
my dad introduced me to gaming but i
would say he
impacted me the most besides my dad the
most
go for me but you know rest in peace
it's like i said you guys can do
anything on that go fund me i'd
appreciate it no doubt man i'm sorry for
your loss and that happened just now
i've seen something happen and your mood
changed so i didn't know what was going
on i was going to talk to you after but
yeah rest in peace to him and his family
and everything man because we got gaming
brothers and sisters people who
influenced us into the game so if you
guys have anything in your heart to
contribute please do and uh thank you
adam for bringing that to my attention i
had no idea
um gonna try to lighten the mood a
little bit we're gonna move on we got
a lot of topic well actually just two or
three times not too much but um
yeah so we got embracer group man this
is king's topic but i'll set it up and
um
yeah they're quite made some
acquisitions you know what i'm saying so
let's first start with the acquisition
piece so it looks like uh three of
square enix development studios will be
acquired by embracer group for a 300
million
deal as embracer has announced in a
press release other pc gamer um
phil rogers ceo of square enix and
europe american europe is quoted as
saying a br embracer is the best kept
secret in gaming a massive decentralized
collection of entrepreneurs whom we are
thrilled to become a part of today so
the three studio is going to be crystal
dynamics idols montreal and square um
enix montreal those crystal diamonds
working on the tomb raider um
using it in region five idols by uh my
troll is responsible for guardians of
the galaxy
and square enix montreal were for known
for their mobile games and hitman go and
so forth and
basically these studios come from an
extensive catalog including tomb raider
deus ex thief legacy of kane the press
release the press release notes state
the acquisition also includes the
continued sales and operation of the
studios more than 50 bat catalog games
now king i know this is your topic you
also wanted to talk about
marvel's playstation this week yeah i
don't know normally he'd get them all in
the place we'll double back and get to
them
[Laughter]
we're gonna let them off the hook
so we got the hayachi face what's going
on
if it's okay with king i would like to
add like a sec thing on this yeah uh
it's heavily rumored right now and it
would make sense that square enix is
proactively doing stuff to sell their
company to playstation
[Laughter]
okay this is for those rumors and this
is for all those fake insiders that was
like i'm telling you to deal with idols
is signed you know squid
it hit me
you can look at the tea leaves
the tea leaves
and i'm gonna tell you all the crystal
dynamics you know because they came over
and
are you implying that insiders had this
wrong
yo they have been exposed
y'all have been exposed
cause i got insiders man
they had told me they had seen the white
sheets
series the next one was gonna be made by
microsoft
i love you guys i love you so much y'all
be thirsty so bad to make some content
this is nice go for it
you know what's funny king
when when i hear a playstation insider
speak
i go ask an xbox insider to see right
let's see this was no playstation dupes
oh he's coming for the community excuse
me talking about oh crystal d they come
here
you remember all of this
microsoft is gonna acquire them yo
only thing i can say with this whole
embrace of group stuff is y'all out here
looking at the wrong demons
i don't want microsoft to acquire
activists you wanna embrace a group to
get them
y'all don't even know what abrasive
group is
[Laughter]
like who's this embracing group and why
are they buying people
[Music]
outside i didn't know them and um thq
nordic's the same yeah
yeah
they they they took some lumps they went
back in the bushes took some steroids
they came out a whole lot stronger than
they went in the bushes with and these
dudes thq nordic yeah it used to be a
joke yeah i used to see that label on
the block and be like wow that's a
mediocre game
y'all know that chq in order to get like
i don't know
later when the 3d graphics started
coming when it was cartridges they were
booboo
but right now
all you fake insiders oh you i'm in the
know guys i i picked this title
because i had to listen to all y'all
speculation taco knowledge of
speculation
we got
[Laughter]
y'all all seen it y'all know it it all
smells funny
stop trying to make content let's see
this is when you try to make content and
let it just happen now you can
organically speculate yes
speculating
that
yeah right we have a fun speculation
no no definitely a prediction
that's all it's about
with the fact that activision that deal
is uh prohibiting microsoft for making
these moves because don't you think that
move was more in line with a microsoft
thing for those yeah
right so
i don't think they're able to acquire
anything their hands is tired because
the feds is in the defenses in the truck
going through this stuff right now
making sure that they don't have nothing
everybody on the highway is speeding
past because they're not worried about
them they already got they fished right
now
and and i told you playstation dude
y'all was laughing ha ha ha ha ha
now they're looking over at y'all too
now
you talking about they looking at that
looking at the bungee dude yeah we're
gonna act like they ain't say wait a
second man when they get that where they
get that money from check books we
already know playstation bro how to get
that money bro
so
so
this embracer thing
the reason why they got sold
just real quick and and and i want to
get y'all your thoughts on this
that iep
from uh
avengers and guardians of the galaxy
was very costly and they they probably
had a budget and they they probably had
a forecast of at least 10 years because
it was a games of a service game like a
destiny
they said they lost 200 million 200
million
and it was the butter the jokes at every
uh earnings call
every time they went there so the
writing was on the wall for the seal
just like uh um addicts said they
allowed crystal dynamics to go and work
on another which was unheard of we would
like to get them out the building yeah
yeah it's like it's like they asked them
to go work on another title in the
moment because the dynamics like they
just shut the door along
what was what was that joke
we had to go change
[Laughter]
was it was it destined to be if
microsoft wasn't tied up with this
what's going on because i mean i may
joke and laugh at these insiders and
maybe they wore on to something right
maybe they did have right information
like my man uh jason schreyer had right
information but somebody gave it to him
wrong and went left
that's my man
but i'm just saying maybe they had right
information and this activision deal
came in and messed up everything right
and they couldn't acquire them no let's
hear it man let's get let's get up okay
the biggest question i would have for
you is do you think that let would you
as you king would you go back
on wanting them to buy that if it meant
they bought these other companies no no
get activision now
interesting let's get the speculative
one himself first what we thinking man
when this news hit embrace a group man
embrace her
yeah i'm guilty of a lot of speculation
he's like
because that's like the that's also the
era that we're in right now right like
this stuff is happening and that's
literally our job as podcasters is
speculating
right like that's yeah 100 but there's a
difference between speculators saying
i know that scene that you know yeah
that's about to happen i'm talking about
them people i don't know what they'd be
drinking
that's all i'm gonna refer to them
square enix is being bought by sony and
then when it doesn't happen all we're
going to do is point in line
but
the sad thing is that they have no shame
because after they do that and everybody
laughs at them like three weeks later
they'll say something else in the same
place it's like
it's like going over these you know yeah
it's like
it's like they went through that phase
where you're scared of rejection at
first but now since they're not scared
of rejection they're just out there and
they outside with that info they're
saying everything they can do you should
never be afraid to fail
i'm done there's one what are these go
ahead that's gonna end up being right
y'all messy continue
i mean oh so for real though like we i
don't think a lot of us knew exactly how
handicapped microsoft was going to be
right because there's like certain
studios like are they publishers that
was off the table
blizzard thing happened it's like okay
well like can they pull off a studio
right because there's so many studios
that have been kind of linked and tied
to them like like now certain affinity
like that's the most thing that makes
the most sense for me because like they
literally have been a support studio for
so many ips that xbox is going to own
now including halo right they've already
been a support studio for them for a
really long time and then also you know
they're working on another project
supposedly for them uh so with all of
that stuff going on it's like it makes
sense but
then it's like you see this deal go
through and it's like 300 million and
you get the studios of a studio it's
already working on a xbox project plus
you get all that ip
you know even just for the tomb raider
ip alone
you know you would think it's like
approaching somewhat around uh that
level like yeah i don't know 100 how
much those go for but
um
300 million tag was crazy that was so
low mad i'm calling the bank too man can
i borrow
it's like this 300 be in my buying range
i love my threesome i love how we we all
say only 300 buddy like like like we got
it
only three if i would have known it was
going to be that much i would have
right you know like
what's wrong with them only 300. no i
mean we could have gotten some investors
together let's go
we're looking at the bigger deals
yeah in comparison it seems for the ip
because what usually drives the price up
is the ip yeah and this came along with
some pretty good ip now
a lot we bought some debt too so we
don't know how much that that was i
think the debt was 100 uh uh 100 million
of debt and it was 200
uh something
i think it was 100 million in debt i
think they split the debt what it seems
like to me is they just bought the ip
and they were willing to take on the
load of the students right right because
the studios were about like breaking
even over the course of like the last
several years like it's supposedly so
that the financials came out like one it
was like
like point five percent profit the other
one was like 10 or something right but
it's like one
um it's like one of those things where
they're looking at the contract and they
forgot a zero and the lawyers just
signed it just sorry
but i i just have a hard time thinking
that xbox maybe wouldn't have wanted to
make this move just because i already
have them working on one of their ips
and if they are considering doing a
sequel right this guarantees you with it
with that ability of a team that's very
familiar with the franchise so that's
where i was thinking that okay maybe
they wanted to now this lets me know
how
handicapped they are and it's not
necessarily that they can't do it it's
just about it's i think the activist
blizzard deal is just
too big to risk it
questions continue it's too big to risky
if they do that it's like is it going to
add fuel to the fire is the ftc going to
use that in their in in all this like
negotiation
considerations and all that so now i'm
thinking all these other rumors are out
there wb games studios potentially being
sold off
microsoft you know hands are tied
potentially if they didn't go after
crystal d are they willing to make a
move there then now the ubisoft stuff's
out there and it's like hey the they're
i i think that right now it's like the
big dog is kind of you know preoccupied
and you're seeing a feasting from
the other people right
that's what's going on
but i think i think i mean like what i
would hate to see is certain studios
that i think are a really good fit like
give me examples get
like certain affinity who would you
based on your theory
right if you said microsoft's
preoccupied right and the deal the
structure and the stakes of the deal who
what would hurt you
lord mav
if microsoft wasn't able to acquire
during this period of trying to land
activision blizzard netherrealm um
i'm with you bro
wait you bro hear that yeah
it's just like these other guys like
it's just like idos and crystal
i don't see no more crystal d in the
chat
you're stupid that was foul you had to
do it like this it's not even deer
it's gone it's like it never existed
messy
because if let's say sony goes out and
they're able to make a play for for the
for uh they're on the watch
now they are but that's a 3.6 billion
dollar watch as opposed to a 70 right i
mean you got one dollar and i got a
million dollars and we both spend hour
last right there we spend it all you
spend your dollar i spend my million who
had more money mm-hmm i will agree on
kingdoms
they're probably being watched too but
not anywhere the degree that microsoft
let them jump out the window i do feel
like they could buy stuff and they could
probably most likely get away with it
but like microsoft's being watched by
the fbi
sony being a japanese studio and then if
they acquire a studio that's not an
american studio then like you know it's
more than likely you're not going to
yeah cause y'all ain't gonna say
anything y'all could y'all not go i'm
gonna snitch
i'm gonna smash i'm calling this when
you gonna call the governor you're gonna
call me
i'll be right on the farm dude
[Laughter]
they also got the exclusivity for the
street fighter and they got potentially
mortal combats
like so you ain't like you appreciate
dudes you're telling me
you wasn't you was about six nine i'm
outside it's almost like that sounds
like a fighting game but not only to me
i don't know oh my god
because king did that someone's gonna
rip that picture right there from king
and put a six-nine on your phone listen
they're gonna give me the color here
they're gonna give me six nine
six nine face i'm snitching on you you
gonna get that back put that in case
okay you didn't appreciate another base
questioning and going to legislation
about activation blizzard you didn't
appreciate that i'm a snitch too you you
snitched on me hey put that nothing down
imagine like imagine like a store you
got sony microsoft just browsed and you
got tencent over there and it's my
king just sitting there hiding behind
the the profile of sony
he's hiding behind the noodles and
noodles he's hiding behind the noodles
the noodles line with some magnifying
glass they pick up something all you
hear is a microphone it says put that
down
i'm gonna tell you right now i'm like
i'm gonna ten cents stay on that
embracing group still everybody else
stealing i'm going right behind sony i'm
profiling uh what you got in the back
sir
you like the walmart grocery shop around
here
you're like
like the not cop guy like the the the
mall cop guy like the guy
the 80 year old
[Music]
will be good enough to go let me go
you know what i mean you just want to
see if they're able to do something else
you know besides like another room
something like that small or whatever so
let's get it yeah
i i mean it's a big deal activision
blizzard right yeah i mean it does it
goes far beyond just like call of duty i
mean you got all these other aspects and
it's 70 billion dollar deal they can't
risk losing it and we see now
i believe with this other deal that
happened
how careful they're going to be not to
mess that up exactly right no doubt so
i'm just wondering what else is going to
happen in the meantime because we got
you know once the activist blizzard
thing happened i mean
you saw in the reports uh because they
have to disclose all this stuff yes that
deal came together in like a month yep
like from the first conversation until
until it was announced to the public it
was literally about like a month maybe
six weeks tops right so you see these
other rumors start swirling you know
from
not just from like
insiders or like gamers or whatever but
from like actual like
wall street stuff you know bloomberg
wall street journal these different
things
and when these rumors start swirling
about this kind of stuff usually
you know stuff could move pretty quickly
so
i think that you know there could be
some more moves while xbox is occupied
right now you know we got to see how it
plays out lord slo-mo backslap of the
dps podcast and the scum podcast how are
we doing sir what are we feeling man
embraces outside 300 million what's
going on
hey look man they got back i want to
know who their who their team is their
lawyers because they got some great
negotiating skills over there man 300
million
look uh sony let's be real here that
that was extortion that wasn't oh
that was we got dirty on you you called
several we won so it's like don't it
kind of seemed like square enix was like
look man just just get this off of us as
possible
like
you know let me put my speculation hat
on let's go let's go
i'm not saying sony's in the building
but somebody is talking to square enix
they're trying to get rick cut the fact
that the stuff that's not profitable
somebody somebody trying to glue some
weight get sexy for someone else
[Laughter]
i'm using that snow drop engine powder
continue no but no look it does seem
like that like look for the past six
months i've been watching square enix
just like sneak this their own studio
yeah
for months with like comments like maybe
maybe we chose the wrong developer to do
a uh a live a live service game but i'm
like who says that about their own death
yeah
privately you don't say that in public
to moment you say your wife can't cook
the relationship over exactly like that
could that can't could not have gone
well right and then
they talked about how we wish guardians
of the galaxy was so better at launch
you know what
is a trash publisher i mean they make
some good games
but when it comes to publishing
miss management i'll be honest with you
they're kind of hit and miss even the
games they make yeah
well you're right slow mo too like whose
fault is it that those games didn't
succeed yeah is it the devs or is it the
publisher like
you know
who was watching you played the
adventures game the first half of the
game plays like a typical crystal
dynamics
single player narrative driven wrong
story game and then halfway through it
it just like somebody flipped the switch
yeah and then all of a sudden now we got
co-op now stories all over the place
i agree completely it's like slow-mo
someone someone told them this is the
game we want not the game you want need
to make exactly yeah you see that and
you know what kind of developer they are
the quality that they made before and
then now you got them doing something
that they don't do this isn't like they
will respawn
dig jedi fall in order right and they
when built a whole new studio and hired
people who made games like that before
successfully right to make that kind of
game that's this isn't like playground
games making the whole second studio to
do fable this is the same team that made
tomb raider now trying to do something
that they've never done and we see how
sony out here would acquire bungie to
help help teach their devs or other devs
that's working under them how to make
live service games but square enix don't
even do that they're just like yeah you
figure it out yup no whatever
all that happens when it fails and
they're like
that's their fault
your blame is uh solely on square
no
i mean the parent because i mean the
parent didn't tell the kid go get
dressed in the room and then when he
went outside with his shoes on backwards
you know um who fault is it but
it's also it's like
they're not known for doing those type
of games and the question becomes like
who
initiated it to be a live service
because i agree with slo-mo like when
you play marvel avengers it starts off
like like no it's a great story yeah
like the story is fine and then it just
midway just transforms into something
else so it's like who's fault today
because it almost feels
like for the loss for the yeah for the
l's that they're taking financially to
me it feels like the western division is
the scapegoat for this
like that's what it feels like that's
the optics they give do you agree slow
or do you disagree no i agree i agree
this seems to be like a scapegoat
forward and then like look at guardians
was a single-player game
they really captured the feel of the
actual character the story was great
hilarious
as well
but that was a loss as well but that
also failed because of the because of
adventures people still had that bad
taste in their mouth as well and and
also the way they showcased guardians at
e3 last year was horrible
they just showed 20 minutes of the same
gameplay that we just saw with the venus
without rare 100 touching on the things
that make guardians special right yeah
they did not sell that game properly to
us and also because they screwed up with
a very
similar like another marvel game from
another square enix western we're
assuming it's going to be another
failure yeah and it wasn't until the
gamers actually got their hands on that
game and the gamers started speaking up
hey yeah
right i think it was it was mainly
how they showed us to that game because
like the casual person that they're not
going to know that this is made by
another square enix studio like that
marketing is so important
and even if
you could waste a bunch of money
that's fine but it's better to
if you're not going to go out there and
spend millions upon millions upon
millions on marketing it's better the
marketing you do do to be effective and
actually show your game in a good light
like you could you could you could you
can spend 500 million dollars on bad
marketing you ain't gonna do nothing or
you could spend half of that on good
marketing that's actually gonna sell
your game and i feel like square enix
has been looking for out for this game
for a while yeah like i feel like
they've been
they it's like one of those things where
like
maybe it's just the eastern to western
thing it's like
when you have western studios working
for an eastern uh uh source or you know
the other way around yeah maybe they
just didn't know how to appeal to a
western market but then like i mentioned
earlier like they're kind of hit and
miss with their own games right you know
final fantasy 15 to a lot of people felt
like it was disappointment i ain't felt
like they made a good final fantasy
since 12. and that was an okay final
fantasy not a good background i would
say they haven't had a good one since
nine let's go
like like 10 was good 10 was good wow
okay i don't care if it's tim but don't
know seriously like
what you guys saying about guardians is
true especially the marketing i would
say probably it's not bad but the
weakest part of guardians is the combat
everything else like is so much greater
and better than the combat you kind of
go like it was not great but it's not
terrible yeah but how did they decide to
market the game to was the very first
thing they showed was the combat yeah
and then like a seven minute like
unedited just trump of like us half of a
a mission it was just like what is this
yeah like especially coming off of as
bab said the disappointment of the
avengers
clearly a lot of the audience just
completely checked out from there so
when the game launches turns out it's
actually a really good game
there's nobody checking for it it got it
started to gather steam from word of
mouth but at that point it's too late
again this comes to square enix not
really knowing how to manage things we
always hearing about how dev's saying
man we i ain't got paid yet man
[Music]
there's been other devs that have said
similar things it's just i'm not i'm not
shocked i'm actually happy for these
developers to move on and potentially
not you know get uh get it on every time
they they drop a game hopefully uh the
new next tomb raider does really well uh
i want to see what else monster all does
hopefully with a deus ex game soon in
the future but i and to kind of to touch
on something the map said i wouldn't
completely rule out
microsoft never getting crystal dynamics
right they're not necessarily really a
publisher like that so like they if if
they can make a profit by acquiring
crystal dynamics off a massive discount
and then to microsoft mark that that is
this this is more valuable to you i
think
so i mean this is just some fun
speculation okay
okay
all right so i'm just i'm just saying
i'm just i just want to back up to that
point so you should so you think it's
some shady underhanded business like yo
listen my man cops is watching us right
now i want you to hold us back
oh my god until i get back
the stuff that they wanted and said yo
when you finish with the fans wait wait
wait wait i sell that back to you on
double on the rehab
he said that abrasive group went over
there was like i see the feds got you
right now
just hit me on the rim just just just
look out for the kids
wow
i agree with you know slo-mo not not in
the you know you holding the illegal
stuff
you ate with that part it's kind of like
it's kind of like that that moment in
the um what's that game uh a ways out
where they're where they're they're
searching the cell for contraband and
you're swi and you're you're giving the
contraband to the dude beside you then
when they search itself you give it to
the other dude like i don't agree with
that i do feel like there is there is a
thing that if perfect dark comes out and
it hits
i feel like it's going to be easier to
go up to uh you know devolve not default
embrace your group and say
i'm gonna give you 300 million for that
one studio that you paid for all the
studios
so and i feel like there is a realm
where that happens because if perfect
art does well and it makes microsoft
money give them a very good game i feel
like microsoft would be willing to spend
that kind of money on it and that's my
point
the chat after microsoft come out of the
you know the fed little locker you're
acting like there's some conspiracy
going on
the chats that
group is the swedish stash house
so listen math
are you hearing what i'm hearing because
this is what i'm hearing they trying to
act like no
it's organic it'll happen if if these
dudes do it right yeah yeah yeah yeah
walk over there pick the bag be nice
alright see you later have a nice day
bye
i did that for them you know i put them
on
[Laughter]
but you know embracer could be like to
slow mo's point though it may not be
necessarily as something as direct as
that but it could just be kind of seeing
what's going on and being like hey we
can get this for a really good deal
right now and later on we might be able
to flip it yo hold on i got to jump
protocol i gotta jump protocol on super
chat shout out to joe delmore follow
some chat microsoft brought crystal d
and they put it in a mama's name
embraces god
oh man
and just imagine crystal crystal they
just announced this new tomb raider game
right like an unreal showcase that new
tomb raider game comes out on unreal
engine 5 and it blows up right
let's say they would do multi-plat it's
everywhere and it becomes a huge success
at that point how much is crystal d and
tomb raider worth right
they may have just win like tripled
their money i will i will say let me
just hilarious i will just say the kids
point as far as like
we don't know because a lot of people
are nervous what's this deal with that
like what happens with perfect dog what
happens now the initiative and we don't
know contractually what's in place right
they could have something to say hey a
year two years a sequel or whatever but
it is interesting that you know because
clearly
embracing group is unique in the sense
that there's no
platform right there's no
service they're just
hoarding in a sense right and it's like
well
well are they hoarding to flip it
are they hoarding to eventually have we
don't know what the end game so to speak
from embrace but we haven't heard
anything
super negative like almost like a
tencent we haven't heard any of that
type of energy so it is interesting to
see what will happen with all these
things they are acquiring i would i i do
think that if they if microsoft say like
a year and a half two years from now
ends up like acquiring cd from embracer
group they're going to get the tomb
raider ip with it too because like if
you think about
in terms of like
if you're microsoft my portfolio what do
i provide that is like say a counter to
my competition you could you could
present to me as a counter to
uncharted you know like i could have my
own my home
finally follow the cards
bro i wanted christmas
when that day happened me and you're
going to do it slow a show and i'm going
to tell them how slow
is the profit
[Laughter]
the day after the deal of activision
blizzard gets announced yes yes
it will be an announcement of crystal
dynamics now being sold to xbox akw said
akw said
snowball
here's the thing
here's the thing i'll go ahead and go
um
i'm glad that this happened to be honest
with you because i do feel like
i feel like square enix was never going
to truly do anything with these western
studios
i feel like
for a while now they felt like they're a
burden more than they're helping them
and it's like i said they can barely
hold their own house and people in the
chat was saying that uh that final
fantasy vii was bad no i don't think the
remake was bad i mean we're talking
about everything else in the past like
15 20 years of their core studios making
the only hit i really feel like they
truly have is final fantasy vii remake
and
that arguably when i see first spoken i
feel like that's another miss
i got to play the game obviously it's
just like nothing they've shown me is
appealing to uh the world and nothing so
it's just like
when it comes down to it
they're clearly
not in a bad place but not in a good
place at all okay so
i do think there's a good chance that
you know in the next
six months to a year we once uh once the
the the bungee things are uh official i
feel like they sell to sony like i
really you know be crazy if they sell to
microsoft we didn't know this was the
whole thing that would be crazy if i was
going to cut with that one that would be
crazy it's just like
i do think that there is a chance that
a good chance that once perfect dart is
finished
and if that's a good showing and they in
the in the game does well
i feel like
at that point
daryl gallagher showed them we have
we have a studio
and then he he's probably gonna be able
to leverage the only reason we got this
game is because of cursor dynamics right
we need them yeah and i feel like they
end up buying uh crystal dynamics and
they end up merging them with the
initiative
but the question is if they do that
what about tomb raider are they going to
like rotate between perfect dark and
tomb raider are they going to make a new
game after tomb raider i don't know what
would you guys want would you guys want
them to continue the the tomb raider
thing or maybe make another third person
i think i mean tomb raider is a is a iep
that's well known i think that that's
something that you should continue but
they've already they already got three
games down
so
i mean we're going to in that
that's
after this fourth one so that would be
four games in the tomb raider bloodline
from this remake
i feel like at that this one's another
reboot right like this yeah yeah yeah oh
it's another reba i don't know i
personally feel like
crystal dynamics is one of the few
companies
that can make a naughty dog level game
it's just i feel like they got to be
probably funny they haven't got this one
flow that's why i was excited
they got to be properly funded and have
that talent and i honestly and truly
feel like they can make that last of us
type of game but they got to make their
own ip yeah because the only way that
you truly make something like that is
original ideals and the tomb raider you
still got to go through a template you
got to have tomb raider laura croft you
got to do what she does like i feel like
if you give them the free reigns to make
those they could make a hashtag just
whatever you can give me something on
last of us levels not for you
you know they they can still do all of
that and just open multiple studios you
know like we see we see mult we see but
then we're seeing doubling down on the
studio right is microsoft willing to be
doing that i don't know maybe
and if they if they don't
like power has multiple studios
and i get that but they they have what
10 15 years of
of history with microsoft to justify
that kind of
that kind of uh
uh investment undead labs and then labs
has opened the studio in new orleans
okay and they've worked with microsoft
since the arcane version the arcade
version of the original 360 version you
need to have a history with with
i don't think microsoft should get no
maybe behind the leeway maybe micros
maybe daryl gallagher could could get
the multiple teams but i don't see
microsoft just openly buying someone and
like okay here's another here's another
500 million to make another team like i
feel like you're gonna have to protect
but they've been working with them since
the 360. they had an exclusive state of
decay game on there there was a lot
neither of them have sold like
blockbusters so it's like it's not like
but they still know what's going on over
there they this is a stupid argument
anyway like we really already we are
about something that didn't even happen
like i'm like
where are we going
yeah hypotheticals anyway let me get my
balls off because i already talked so um
look this this was definitely surprising
i didn't see this one coming from
embracer salute to them um
i will say i do see a lot of people
upset they're bad a lot of people very
angry you know what i'm saying that
microsoft how did they allow this to
happen and to me it's like microsoft
don't buy one studio and i would have
microsoft let this still go yeah it's
like bro like this i feel like if it was
microsoft though there would have been
another zero added
they know they could afford that they
would put another zero adder it's just
to me like just join a baseball cards
for them this ain't fantasy league
football like people
the mistake i feel gabers make is they
sit there and they go they look at the
ips right and they'd be like yo that's
hot right like two minutes let's be
honest we all love you know tomb raider
dance sex and see them i'm peasy like yo
those are fire games but people are not
understanding the business
the business is you look at it and like
what king is saying if dead
if marvel avengers is bleeding money if
guardians of the galaxy as great as it
is is bleeding money see gamers we love
to talk about other people pocket
yeah they should do this this that's
pocket watching like that does not make
money that's not good business so we got
to stop with the pocket watcher because
it doesn't work like that at the end of
the day i've always said this like
to me when the activision blizzard thing
happened i'm gonna be 100 with y'all i'm
not really in that ecosystem as a
hardcore gamer anymore right so it
didn't initially announcement appealed
to me as a hardcore gamer but then when
i sat back and i looked at it like damn
call of duty's like the number one
selling you know what i'm saying
franchise then they get the mobile arm
right with king then they get you know
what i'm saying the blizzard and the pc
stuff then you look at the big picture
and you go as a bit that is a smart move
and then oh by the way y'all happen to
having some uh
uh some sexual allegations and some
problem
that's right how unfortunate for you let
me sweep in and help
like let's be real like microsoft does
things when it's to their advantage when
it makes business sense if you kind of
look at it so to me as much as i love
crystal dynamics and all these guys like
you have to look at them objectively
they're not
making money like you could be
inheriting a loss and think about this
if it's 300 sony ain't other people
ain't kick the tires either
yeah other people were like oh
you know saying so again we gotta be
careful because as gamers we want what
we want you know to say kind of thing so
that that was the thing i did notice
with the situation i do feel like you
know i've happy embracer got them in a
sense because let's be real if you're if
you play in the xbox ecosystem what
really has changed
right you're still going to be able to
play these games you're still going to
be able to do what you need to do so
it's just like you know and we
historically you know there could still
be game pass deals and stuff like that
we've seen them work with you know
embrace our sub-level so that's just
where i'm at i'm more excited for um
legacy of cane i hope they do something
with that that's one of my my series
that i do like and um yeah we just got
to see what happens but i'm in total
agreement with king i mean i've been
telling people yo the block is hot
everything for as far as your xbox fan
you care about what microsoft is going
to acquire
you know
if you're thinking big publisher i just
don't see i would be shocked you know
i'm saying during this period it is too
hot all attentions on the microscope is
on them they are half they have to show
and all hands on deck that that deal
goes through and then if it goes through
yeah maybe during this pit maybe you
could sneak another run maybe you could
speak something on a smaller individual
level but on this big grandiose level no
and i think it's gonna there's gonna be
a reality check for some other studios i
got you at it that
may get acquired
during this period when people like yo
how microsoft let that go through
because they could be focused on that
yeah attic i'll let you go then we get
about here
i feel like
certain things make sense
mm-hmm some warner brother makes sense
like you know rockstar rocksteady
uh netherrealm that makes sense
but crystal dynamics is the only thing
that makes sense for microsoft like
as far as all the western studio score
enix i'm sure they would be good for
microsoft yeah but they don't make sense
to risk a deal for mike they bleeding
money 300 million out here right if the
if the if the activist blizzard thing
wasn't
a thing i agree right i i feel like
it
i could see 100 like how it would it
would work right like it's just already
working on a game you know like they
don't want anything to do with you over
at square galaga got the relationships
you don't got to break the bank for
either you know apparently like yeah
imagine if you just bought crystal
dynamics how much all of it was if you
just buy crystal dynamics
give me what you spend every year on
food and you can
just get that tomb raider ip alone
though it is huge
i told people man look block is hot i
told people when i you know what i knew
when i saw
slow and i saw that forward facing
statement from microsoft about call of
duty yep
i'm like what is this oh we're gonna put
this on all platforms and we're creating
an ecosystem that i'm like why you paint
yourself as this whole it's switching
and everyone's gonna be like
okay
yeah i'm like okay
we know historically
when they buy
it's theirs they were quick to let you
know starfield was theirs the bethesda
is theirs
right so this was different energy and
i'm like why then i'm like okay with the
legislation and the political ground
standing and people trying to make an
example out of big tech the block is hot
y'all keep telling people i i just i
just hope at the end of the day
the bag is secured over here you know
they come out and they be able to go
pick up their belongings from them
you know what's going on to this formula
this process started and microsoft
came out and they sent the engagement
letter it was accepted and they're going
through the legal process
it's like everyone else was on the phone
with each other yo the clients can't do
nothing like yo what up bungie well the
microsoft tried to buy them last year
they get them on the live we can't let
this go through because people don't
realize a company like microsoft not
bidding in open bids because they know
they can't really do anything with it
i'm sure they're in there trying to see
like but if microsoft isn't a huge force
you have to deal with you can outbid a
lot of other people because google ain't
really out in these streets like that
anymore like ever since the stadium
thing went down a little bit i'm sure
they're in there but they're not in
there in there yeah ted cent has their
own problems in china right now they
ain't really in there like they used to
be so it's really between sony and the
big publishers right now so it's just
like when you don't have money ain't got
money there imagine trying to outbid
someone that you knew that there's no
way you could outbid if they really
wanted it
if microsoft really wants something
there's nothing there's oh there's very
few companies on this earth that can
stop them from getting that company yeah
if they really want and knowing that
they can't come out there and just throw
the oh sony you want them that's cute
we gotta see them only that they can't
do that i feel like that's why you see
the budgies being bought right now you
see the the square enix is selling right
now because they know that most likely
microsoft's not gonna pull up and knock
on the door and then the moment that
other company opens like
sony microsoft's at my door
oh it's it's it's like it's like well
what'd he say
oh we gotta see you know shout out to
hoga we had him on he's in agreement and
he just said you know he can't see
any bigger type dude he's a possibility
with a smaller deal you know what i'm
saying but we got to see how this plays
out but we got to move on these last two
joints in there you got super chat's
ready just in case or should we fire up
and then do the afterwards i'll get them
real quick real quick um
let me bring it up
no doubt shout out to him we got a
[Music]
five dollar shoe trap from looney boy
two
[Music]
yeah microsoft is going to buy
immigration group down the road
they are a glorified holding company
they sitting on ips not producing
anything it's actually false um
tc uh
um
no yeah thq nordic actually does make
games
so and if they're the same company they
are doing stuff it's just
they had a lot of
they had a lot of games at the game
awards last year
like four or five showings i think arc
raiders is one of them too oh yeah it's
just
part that
benefits microsoft if once this
activation thing's going is embrace your
grip they're not really a publisher so
it would be easier to acquire that
because sure they they will use
crystal dynamics
but
they don't need crystal dynamics and i
felt like score enix even though that
they were being kind of disrespectful to
the washington studios they needed them
to appoint uh we got a 10 super chat
from uh uh from sage said youtube sage
salute sage
microsoft can buy crystal and adios i'll
probably butcher that but we'll go
and and those ips from embracer the
offer is big enough they have to
consider all the offers to maximize
value to investors the thing is is when
microsoft's not in the room bidding
obviously that that price is going to
come down the price of the brick is an
expensive one
look who put your powder down
[Laughter]
yesterday's price is not today's price
continue we
crystal d is still in the building oh
that perfect dart hit the street we got
our hands all that all in that bag oh
i'm talking about the futures wow okay
that's all you got to say moving on
gotta find superchat for mr irishman
uh
i'm probably gonna butcher this dude's
name uh since
yo show my susu
yosuke masuda there we go
or whatever he said
it took over square they went downhill
uh yorker taru
put uh put him in near automata as a
secret
you see yakuba
i didn't know the holdup hold up did he
play his ex-boss in the game is a secret
boss i didn't know he did that that's
crazy a cigarette maybe he was trying to
warn us okay then we got a four super
trap from uh the dawn uh cjg
where did embracer's money all come from
just selling games or are they putting
that p2 are they pushing that oh they
put you that feed too okay
now embracer is into other industries as
well so they
they
their investment
groups
they're another they're another tents
they're in everything
then we got a five dollar secret from uh
from joe
microsoft bought crystal d and put it in
that mama's a name
that was fine five super chat continue
and then we got a five dollar super from
uh
lucious augustus yeah and bracer is
hoarding the content for the upcoming
content war embracer has all the double
a games that fill up subscription
service that's money money he actually
has a huge point there because i do
agree that out of all the people
and brycer and thq nordic have those ips
that can easily be switched to a triple
a product
yeah and they have deep silver too don't
they
do yes they do they have deep silver
they also have media the darksiders
franchise and the mercenaries franchise
if i remember correctly yes they gotta
have your favorite p's
then that guy they find out that you can
trap from uh sujitsu sage obsidian got
multiple teams obsidian has worked with
microsoft for years
uh but i'm not gonna argue uh some of
you in this level you will yeah we got a
two dollars rich i'm too much
opinionated mr two opinionated how about
a tomb raider plus indiana jones spindle
that would be that would be lit i
equalize tomb raider
that'd be crazy but apparently that game
is um
like multiplied
i don't think they've ever come out
officially confirmed that but i don't
know
gotta find out super shot from gaming
forte no no hold up we got jd gamer
before yeah jd before
got a five dollar super chat from uh jd
gamer i don't see microsoft buy all of
embrace your group with its 14 000
employees but elios and cd cd uh
man crystal dynamics will be coming home
in just a couple years get all that i
don't even
i could see them going after crystal
dynamics but nothing else
um five dollar superchat from gaming
four to happy mother's day to all the
amazing moms of the past
wow for joining the round
shout out to matt for joining the realm
who is that guy slo-mo
and as always hey king boo-boo
and then we got a two-dollar super chat
from han solo gaming
uh what do you guys think of all this
buying will slow down when do you think
all this blind will slow down will he
run out
never because there's certain people
like look it just
the money ain't never going to stop
flowing when you stop throwing dollars
in the club when the money run out
this this slowing down will stop for
some company oh my god moving on you got
donald trump and irishman said you
missed the second his second super chat
that's what irishman said i missed a
second i got while you look for irishman
i got donald taco member for 12 months
and brace are going drop that
subscription service soon and they're
going to have games so dropping every
month with how many studios in ip they
got nobody buying no app called embrace
the app
that sounds like
that who said i missed mr mr irishman mr
irish
yeah yeah oh i'm sorry about that mr ice
with the five superchat i don't want to
see sony by square anything other than
final fantasy would not get made under
sony nier and dragon quest would not get
greenlit under them i think they would i
think they would green let both of those
look
sony does i feel like sony has went away
a little bit from his japanese roots but
they still love that area i just don't
feel like they see as lucrative as like
the western audience when it comes to
something like naughty dog the games
that they make the god of wars but i
don't think they would just say no like
dragon quest has been exclusive to
the playstation for a long time but i do
think now as far as like triangle
strategy octopus traveler that stuff
might get caught
i i don't know i don't know if uh that's
a good stuff i don't know if if if sony
acquired square enix if they wouldn't
treat it the way microsoft treats or
xbox streets bethesda where xenomax
media still publishes itself
like they still do their own thing they
just like well this is where it goes is
determined by xbox like you're not
putting those games over there or
anywhere else but how you decide to make
your games and publish and market it
that's still all on you yeah um i think
that's only probably would do the same
thing with square considering that like
even though they're yeah the level of
quality ain't where sony is when it
comes to square for the streets
that's right slow you on to something
since jim is in town everybody get to be
purchased and still do what they've been
doing
you're ridiculous
anyway moving on we got to go if we take
it too long we got to get this popping
with um this topic attic i set you up um
fury fury is in the news so shout out to
um
game breakers
bakers excuse me look at the dev they
announced surprise new dlc drop for
intense action game fury and they said
uh this was actually six years after the
first game release but the bad news is
that it's set to come to every platform
except xbox later this month then they
took to twitter they cited that um
they're a small indie team and as far as
limited resources and they actually said
that um it didn't the game never
captured a lot of attention xbox so the
first statement looks like it says we've
heard all of you who play fury on xbox
and we understand your frustration we're
a small indie team and we couldn't find
the time and budget to make that port
fury never captured a lot of attention
on xbox and unfortunately we had to
prioritize platforms we hope to be
developing for xbox again in the future
thank you for supporting our games so uh
yeah this was a bit of a controversy a
lot of xbox fans were upset so addict
you had a lot to say what's your topic
man yeah
let's go i'm gonna let slow-mo go first
because he's the only person i know
disagrees with me
yeah i'm gonna say i think it's a bit of
overreaction okay let's get it um i i do
think that uh um the game bakers is the
the dev they're they're a like 17
developer studio
um they
i i'll use this example for um another
another studio that i thought made a
mistake in releasing some content on all
platforms and that's night school studio
night school studio made oxen free and
they also made after party when they
made oxenfree which was i think a
superior game but also a game that
performed great at launch it launched
initially on pc then it came out on
consoles later on and i think it
eventually hit switch at some point
later on that was like a 12 dev studio
that did that right when they came out
with after party launched on all
platforms all at once
game is not a demanding game whatsoever
but it was a buggy mess at launch i
think when you are a small studio you
don't really have the ability or the the
leeway or the maybe the just the
bandwidth that some of these bigger
studios have right they're releasing on
all platforms i don't want you to have
the con the actual content that players
want to play be
uh up to snuff as far as the quality
goes right right away uh again they they
said it didn't sell that gray on xbox
who knows what the actual sales numbers
were but they also didn't close the door
when they're eventually coming out on
that right so i kind of feel like like i
understand the frustration especially if
you play on xbox you enjoy the game i
tried that out this week on pc it's a
pretty awesome um game i enjoy it uh but
you know the difference here is that
when that when that dlc comes out i mean
i'm gonna be able to play it immediately
versus someone on xbox who
if if you only have an xbox i get it
right yeah but if you have multiple
platforms and you see it's a small dev
i don't see a problem just buying the
game on a different platform and
enjoying that dlc if that's what you
really want to do
because if that game is really that good
you know what's it worth to you yeah
controversy yeah it's on pc get on
playstation sweden okay okay let's go be
a good one lord math man where are you
at with it or let's gonna jump on his
own topic at the end
no i'll go first
[Laughter]
continue
no matt go i'll go oh you're gonna go
last oh okay sorry i thought you made me
gonna go first okay yeah man
yeah i mean i don't think it's a huge
deal you know what i mean like i think
it's something that kind of got blown
out of proportion i i get like why if
you are one of the few people that
bought it why you would be like a little
like oh i bet i wanted that i already
invested in the game right but at the
same time it's like
these small indie teams you got to kept
them some slack sometimes you know what
i mean it's not like
um it's not like through this huge
publisher now if this was like
square or some one of these other big
publishers or that did something like
this and we're going to square will
actually absolutely would be messy like
this
yeah
one thing i want to say about square two
like if you're gonna complain about
sales on all your games stop doing timed
uh or console exclusives
i'm just saying you're cutting your
audience in half anyway but as far as a
game like this you know it's uh
it's just a small indie team but i uh i
don't really personally care
just to tell you the truth i mean i
never played the game
i had no interest in the dlc whatsoever
uh first if somebody is upset about it
hey you know uh yeah like i almost said
go check it out on a different platform
yeah i don't know but like i do
what i find most interesting about it
though is like the fact that they
actually came out and said we didn't
have any success on xbox right that kind
of like jumped out and i think that's
like also being ran with from the other
side where people are saying like oh
it's because it's not a game pass you if
a game's done game pass on xbox it
doesn't succeed and all this kind of
crap right so
just sometimes some games click better
with certain platforms and that happens
on xbox more with a lot of times on
these like
style games
they give a two-hour demo
oh yeah
but sometimes it happens on xbox and it
doesn't click on playstation sometimes
it happens on the opposite side right so
yeah i mean it is what it is you know
like i i don't think it's a huge deal
and i think uh
shout out to people that are excited for
the the dlc that have it on playstation
pc or whatever i'm sure you're gonna get
a fun time
no doubt
king where are we at with the fury dlc
skipping six years late you're worried
about
halo infinite these dudes is six years
late to the party with the first dlc
and then they said yo it didn't sell
right over there if you outraged you
should have purchased baby so obviously
you didn't purchase so why are you
outraged and for you dudes that did
purchase you should encourage your
friends to purchase too
because
right now you got the sad haiyachi face
wow and you like oh man that dlc ain't
coming well pony up there 500 to get
that playstation then you got to buy the
game
or or you could do steam see this is
what happens when you expand your
ecosystem and stop playing on the cheap
stop playing on the cheap all right go
on it speak on it this is they want a
game on the slide you know you see these
dudes they only got a playstation 4
because it was 100 cheaper or oh they
got a little man right now because he's
200
cheaper this is coming from the dude
that won't buy anything yes
in game pass that's all i played that
was like the first we've heard of the
years i'm taking your
call right now i just picked up um what
was that oh
i buy so much stuff and i leave it there
and this is the problem so don't worry
about my pockets worried about yours
um but i say this to say if you're
worried about other people's fault
i'm not worried about their pockets i'm
worried about them whining inside my
twitter so this is because i saw this
i'm like
six years
and you outraged now like
like that's like waiting for your food
for two hours
explain
explain to me the six years part because
i'm confused by how long it took for the
dlc to come out i guess win it again
it's been out for six years that people
still didn't buy the game right
oh wait a second you said the dlc ain't
out yet no no no
no
wait did you think the dlc came out six
years ago no no i said the dlc is coming
out now but the game launched in 2016.
yes yes yes that's six years yes yes
that's correct if you're standing
waiting for your uber for two hours
you're gonna get upset at the two hour
mark or you're gonna get upset when he's
late 15 minutes what happens if i pay
for the uber and it still ain't here no
that's your problem you should get your
refund back
and that's what that's what i told
people on twitter
when you pay for fury you paid for the
game did you know there was dlc coming
when you paid for that that's my point
all right okay
i'll jump
yeah i'm not finished yet because you
got a complete experience and they
decided to release dlc if your block
ain't hot i'm not going over there to
work over there why should i go over
there on your block your block is trash
i'ma go over here with playstation get
it popping and they buying games over
here right this is what they're saying
right they're saying switch is buying
games they're saying playstation is
buying games and it does it's not it's
not cost effective for us to risk making
dlc for a platform that didn't support
the game six years
facts and they did just going to their
demographic where the money is right i
see that and it makes sense to me
i'm a jumper i'm surprised y'all i'm a
little bit with an act on this
of a little bit because this is where
i'm at
your guys are absolutely correct from a
pure business standpoint right you're
absolutely right gamer get my feelings
out of it right if you look at all the
platforms and you say yo we got the
numbers in front of us
xbox numbers wasn't
it or whatever whatever i think what i
struggle with it is just that
the optics from the fact that if you're
a small team
right right and you say they sold the
lease whatever but you're still making
it on pc you're still making it on
twitch you're still so i struggle with
the small team part with this like if
they had a bit like yo the dlc is coming
to playstation because the whole blog
yeah like like how you got enough time
again i don't want to pocket watch
resources but how how you got enough
time to still do these other platforms
but you can't it's just the opposite it
sounds like a choice yes it's just it's
a choice it is a choice and
and i respect them to matt's point
that's why i'm not going to go hard is
that they did say yo the numbers over
there
wasn't what it was right so normally you
don't get that
and i respect that i respect that you
said the numbers wasn't what it was i
the reason why i'm empathetic to attic
on this because part of me is like well
if the numbers were on playstation or
the whoever's the number one and you're
the small team with limited resources
how you got time to do these other dev
kids then
yeah
there's two things right yeah like it
was on it was on ps plus
yeah at some point that helped
tremendously
they probably got back from something
hold on stop right there stop right
there and i love that you said that
because that's where i want to go with
my second point because i see a lot of
this narrative this is why you got to
buy against people this is why because
subscription services are bad but that
game benefited from being in the
subscription platform where the lead
joint is what the numbers are so we
can't have it both ways with this oh
it's it's evil
exactly where it's evil for the industry
so again and then the other thing is
this game came out before
existed so you got to think about 2016
when it came out like that was the
lowest of those for xbox right that was
like thank you
and people still didn't buy it they had
nothing else to play
[Applause]
but i do understand the point and that's
all i wanted to say we got to be i'm
seeing a narrative that this is wrong
this is why you got if you don't buy the
games and this is why it's just not that
you know about the game excuse me sales
do matter but this is why subscription
services are evil y'all see this this
guy this drug came out before the joint
existed and benefited from being in the
subscription service over there so
that's all i'm doing they'll also want
to add i think um and uh shout out to
asian deli that was yes yes yes we were
having this discussion and daley found
the numbers that's good the game fury
sold a total of 700k
um and 40 of that was on peak on steam
oh so so it did didn't have a nice
audience on steam that makes sense why
on steam salute you're going to put it
put that out there we had to do numbers
i don't know about the nintendo numbers
but the switch is like you know high on
the streets for some reason
for individual stuff
no i just want to hear what
i just want to hear what the stuff that
slo-mo's um guest was talking about in
reference to the breakdown
yeah yeah he's the one he was like it
was 700k uh total sales 40 on steam i
don't know about switch okay it came out
december 2021 i mean sorry 2016. which
is like
not too long before the swiftly switch
came out in 2017 right
right so like i don't know like it must
have came out on switch at some point
right before now and it probably did a
decent amount of sales but all that said
look if on xbox it didn't sell great
again they didn't close the door on it
ever the dlc ever coming out on xbox
right true that is true that is true
they didn't close it it could still be a
possibility just that it had to be a
lower priority depending upon you know
okay my last question is i feel what you
say my only my last point to the for
everyone i get on a game level but on a
dlc level it's kind of hard to be like
yo you started this game or what
platform now i gotta go buy it on the
other platform starting from the
beginning then get the dlc that is a
from a from a game style it do feel a
little weird but i i get it at it you've
been patient i know you're ready to go
so i'm gonna let you go
first thing i want to address is this
money issue
so i guess the money wasn't hitting it
six years ago
but two years ago they had no problem
releasing haven on xbox
so
you mean to tell me that
okay we didn't make much from from fury
so i would feel like if you didn't like
the money sales on that
you wouldn't release anything else
back over here
but didn't haven launch your game pass
okay
but that's not a full game
that's not a full game look i don't want
to hear this all buying on under the
platform i gave them money in 2016 and i
expect to have access to anything on
that game going forward don't stay here
and come to me this whatever this studio
because i'm done work at it
okay
say that again that is not how goods
work
okay so
hold on okay
you got a full game they didn't give you
a part of a game right
they gave you a full game it's not like
the last of us right yeah it's not like
factions
it's not like a telltale game that has
episodes and you paid for the first
episode and they was like yeah we done
we ain't giving you two through five
like what
like nah
first off this is a free update second
off they have a playstation 5 upgrade
that doesn't seem to be coming to xbox i
didn't wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
that's a free wait
update oh
this is my issue with it if it was just
for their size then okay i get it you
can't do it but why haven't come out for
the console because they got that money
i get that that's cute why they brought
up money even for 50 years ago you six
years ago you put a game on a platform
and i invested and gave you money you
can't just six years later be like oh i
know that you know we we put this on
here we're gonna pull it the story
continues on the other wait a
so this is this is going to people so
everybody
because what the hell do you bring up
sales numbers for and you out here
giving out free cookies yeah i want the
cookies too
hey now and i don't care if you come
late for cookies and free cookies i want
my cookies too and they said now y'all
if you look back to the history of this
of this podcast you have never come at
me and complained about exclusive dlc
i've went out and bought the final
fantasy 7 remakes i've went out and
bought everything else
i played stuff on steam i went out and
bought stuff on on on nintendo that
doesn't bother me what bothers me is you
initially did a game on a platform
that's right and then six years later
you come out there and say i know we
took your twenty dollars we get
everybody stuff but you that's my issue
this isn't know some some some regular
game that's going on this is a dlc that
they already took my money
give my dlc
they gave you full value of the game
when you boil that launch okay hold on
hold on let's go let's go finish let's
go for this let's look at it did you
know there was a dlc coming for this
game back in 2016. but now i know that
one okay slow-mo slow-mo let me ask you
a question when this uh this dlc in this
expansion whatever the hell you want to
call this comes out is my twenty dollar
investment more than the ps5 investment
is what i'm saying investment
money worth more than life
answer my question does my 20.
[Music]
is that you cannot expect a company to
support something when the on the
platform they are they're wasting their
time and doing so and it's free so bad
it's not the the work they put in for
that apparently it's free on the
playstation on steam you have to pay for
it it's free on the playstation yeah
okay so steen they got to pay some some
cash playstation get it for free how
about nintendo nintendo got this game
nintendo does have the game yes all
right so nintendo getting it for free
i want what nintendo's eating here's my
issue
it would be different if this studio
came out and this studio was new this
studio that made a first game right or
something related to that this studio
literally came out it said yo slow-mo
you getting this on steam we got you yo
big cloud we getting you get on this
playstation 5 we got you oh addy you're
gonna have to go out the back door don't
let the media see you
we don't want no media right now i know
we get i know we took your money we got
you officially maybe baby but you're
gonna have to go out the back door
you're like no
call this dlc in appreciation for the uh
if a company came out there and they
said yo we only had enough money to do x
and x amount we can only get the
playstation 5 dlc we'll do the rest
later
the playstation five and then
it's slow mo's defense they didn't even
know we're not defending what he said
hold on hold on hold on kill him what
i'm gonna say is it is defense they
didn't rule it out completely they
didn't say it's never
hold up you coming out on twitter and
you say we had enough funny to give
everybody something but xbox you guys
have to leave the party we don't like
you we don't respect your money
maybe we might let you into the vip
it's future consideration yeah right you
wait you're waiting to get your wrist
stamped what's going on here
it's the fun with it look we got to see
how this thing play out we will go on
and on fun debate i i i thought this is
speculation
speculation as always man this is holly
your shout out to forte oh fourteen
turned on slow the view of slow mo
backslap does it represent those of the
dps podcast his views are his own and we
wish him well yo that sounds like the
podcast broken up the biggest the
biggest issue i have with this whole
thing is i just have an issue if you
coming out there and you're saying we a
small team we can only do so much but
you got enough time everybody else when
you look at something like that cog
let's say you don't know anything about
this information let's say i'm a studio
i come out there i'm like cog we only
have enough stuff to do limited projects
because we are a small team
when i tell you that statement are you
gonna what are you gonna assume that
they're developing on maybe one platform
one platform yeah generally that's what
i see and if i came out there and if
someone said we're making this on
playstation we making this on steam
we might even put this on the epic game
store we could even put this on on on
everybody
everybody but you
you you go to the back
no you know like you know where they
take the novice king at the club they'll
be like all right you you yeah yeah yeah
you good you good fam you got your
stairs
right is the game the game bakers they
got a long memory okay they got a long
memory and they remember long memory
that they first they completely finished
let's slow finish let's slow finish yeah
so after you took the game pass back you
can't cut your man that's slacking
little bit
something went wrong backstage somewhere
wrong
[Music]
them man go buy them and go put them in
games of id oh my god look i'm just
going to get his id
i don't mind
this practice being used if you if you
help with the if you bought the timed
exclusive on an actual game but i'm like
phil smith i don't like when this is
used for dlc because it doesn't make any
sense
if i invested into you six years ago i
expect you to take my me and everyone
else that bought this game on xbox
into into consideration would you do
anything with that title if you made a
theory 2 and that's only on playstation
switch you know i'd be a little
frustrated but like yo i got a
playstation i'm gonna buy that on
playstation but if you sit you're coming
out for dlc and telling me your money
wasn't good here anymore
they actually like to check out
nobody ain't good look this is your
video do you feel like you got your
money's worth for for what you've spent
on the game before yes but i want my
money's worth
and now in 2022 we're giving you a
mcflurry with it and those dudes over
there just get the mcflurry and you stay
with the value that you had it's this is
not right this is not right and i feel
like you're punishing us for something
that happened back in 2016. you don't do
that that's not how well but they had no
idea
they had no problem taking my money
yeah 2020 they came through with that
game pass back and that didn't absolve
[Applause]
did you play this game back in the day
when it came out
you got a bunch of people up here that
got no connection to this game
whatsoever i expected me to be okay
here's the thing i think we all know we
bought it on xbox
one
how much is it now i'm gonna go buy it
we gotta
[Music]
we'll do
everybody's so with this because either
a they didn't care about this game or b
they got they're like oh it's only xbox
i'll tell you what
they looked over to us and said you
people oh damn
and on my tweet i said i ain't i'm not
supporting that studio anymore because
if they're coming out of the board years
later they're telling me
ain't good enough for me why should i
say my money is good enough for you
i got a solution for you though you
don't know how to play it because what
i'll do is i'll go buy it i'll i'll buy
it on steam and then i'll play it and
stream it and i'll i'll invite you to
watch the stream oh that's slow-motion i
can't bad what's basically i'm a
hypocrite
so we will move on from this we will
revisit this if this comes up and we'll
see how this goes got something we're
gonna just combine this laptop and then
super chat because we're going super
long
yeah so look last one this is just
impressions jeff keagle y'all outside
summer game fest is back 2022 will
feature a slate of digital livestream
shows including a spectacular live
kickoff show hosted by the one and only
jeff keegley filled with world permit
world premieres and days of the devs
with i am 8bit and double fine the fat
the festa will also feature a slate of
two to be announced events from game
publishers and platforms in june stay
tuned for more details so just quickly
thoughts on the announcement and then
the only wrinkle i have for this being
my topic is
in relationship to microsoft
do you think
microsoft we know they got the but
that's the showcase
on the sunday june 12th
do you think anything
of their showcase could be held for jeff
exclusively based on the eyes the the
the zeitgeist of summoning game fest
we'll start with first speculation first
don't spawn with speculation
um yeah i think so because i mean
keeley's been having a lot of stuff for
xbox
at his shows you know the award show
uh last year they had more stuff um the
even the previous two years prior to
that
i i feel like xbox has so much stuff
they have in the works i mean you got
about 50 projects i mean we know several
of them have been even alluded to from
the studios
obsidian has like three projects you got
id we don't know 100 what they're
working on yet you know machine games
has got stuff going on we have all these
game announcements and yet we've yet to
see things right so we if we know that
23 2023 to 2024 2025 is going to be the
years where a lot of this stuff is all
coming out
then they gotta start showing more than
what they've been even though they had
30 games last year right it's crazy we
had 30 games last year people said that
oh they're gonna have like 30 games like
no they have 30 games they had 30 games
right and yet
they're going to have more
this year and the next and the next so
they're gonna have to utilize these
shows man and plus if you are looking to
make it splash right you're looking to
have a uh
a big impact
a keeley show even though it's not
necessarily for your hardcore
you're gonna get a lot of playstation
people that are watching that you're
gonna get a lot of nintendo gamers that
are watching that you're going to get a
lot of people that just play on pc that
are watching it so if you want to try
and invite people to your ecosystem that
aren't already there
it's a good opportunity right and you
can't miss up miss on that like it's
going to have a huge huge audience so i
think maybe they come out with a two or
three things that are pretty strong and
say hey
check this out but also in a few days
you're not going to want to miss what's
coming next right
so one of those
super strong titles be uh starfield
i think we get a teaser for starfield
with an elude to like watch the xbox
showcase right
you know and then i think in the xbox
showcase we see open up straight into
game play with starfield right
get that out of the way at the beginning
and then let everything else because we
know starfield's going to be at the
showcase right
100 we know starfield's going to be
there at the xbox show so get that out
of the way let us be wowed and then
everything else after that be a surprise
fair enough so
lord slomo where are you at jeff keagle
eats outside summer game fest is back
what do you think and what you're
feeling and do you think microsoft will
reserve anything for big g cape
let's look at the dates here what's the
date of keeley show again um looks like
it kicks off on the 9th
but it's a it's a whole saluting of
events yeah yeah yeah so yeah i i do
think they'll kind of do what they did
last year where they showed some things
in the summerfest but then hold off like
a bigger uh rollout of everything for
their own shows i i agree with mav on
that like we might see like our first
glimpse of actual like gameplay or at
least
what we would see in the game and for
star field there or maybe even with rare
fall a little bit there but then
uh as bethesda tends to do when they
when they release their games here is
like everything that you need to know
about the game and it comes out in four
months kind of deal like they did with
fallout 4 and fallout 76 so like i do
think that like on the 12th on that
sunday that's when you'll get like a
full like however time period i think
it's like they're doing like 90 minutes
yeah potentially yep yep
okay like you might see like a good 15
minutes on starfield alone just to
really you know show this game and
everything that you'll be you'll get
into as they normally do for their
bethesda in-house releases but yeah on
the game fest you'll get a little a
little teaser here and then say hey
watch our show in three days kind of
deal so yeah i fully expect that i also
fully expect more 90s rock bands
and a bunch of commercials especially
now that e3 isn't happening you know
jeff keeley won't go in
green day he's probably bringing audio
slaves
[Laughter]
commercials like crazy and then the the
last game of the show was gonna be
uh something clearly was paid for like
like a uh a fast and furious game you
know like you know how you do you know
you know how you do oh my god i think
this question is actually for you i i i
i must admit i'm starting trouble i know
how you feel
about um the show not that you ate the
show but historically you've always felt
microsoft needs to establish
their own show and and and and and debut
their stuff that's the near and dear on
their own show
do you think with this announcement with
our summer game fest that that continues
and that jeff will get something
exclusively or do you think starfield
specifically
will be
kind of only for the microsoft shows
themselves
um
can you share it here yeah you're good
you're good like obs is not good yes
zoom is kind of messing up i mean when
it comes down to it i
i don't want them to show anything like
big like now they just come out there
and they
show something on there that's like you
know stay tuned for
kind of like how they remember
was that game called um the the anthem
how they showed
stay tuned for the uh for the uh the the
the ea no ea the night before said
watch the xbox show for more in-depth
games remember that yes or anthem if i
saw something like that that's okay you
know but i mean they do whatever they
want this is their company but it's just
like to me
if you go out there and you just show
gameplay there for the first time
i'm gonna be pissy
like because it's just like you you
i get it
so if they go my star feel
what they show that jpeg or the xbox
or when they go show it they gotta show
stuff but then they'd be like yo world
premier gameplay on jeff tomorrow
that's gonna set you through the roof
it's not gonna set me to the roof i just
think it's a mistake okay you know i i
do feel like until they take that
seriously they're never gonna truly
build that brand that they want to build
because you know when play they're one
of the reasons playstation does that you
don't see playstation giving the best
stuff to other people you know and i
don't mind if they come out there and
you know they they they want to be part
of it you know if they want to show a
dlc to something you know a wasteland or
a dlc to make not stage k because they
completely starved well with state of k2
but these
i would prefer that on their own
platform especially see these because of
how big it's gone but i'd understand
that but when it comes to those that
that stuff that you could hear and one
more you know i always say that that one
more moment if you give that to someone
else
i don't know
okay
you've changed oh that needs to change
you'd be a little more reasonable people
are angry continue um lord king where
you at man jeff is outside
xbox is outside things online
playstation's outside so all of them was
going over to jeff's show
and they all cuz you know listen how
many playstation fans aren't really
going to tune in to the bethesda xbox
joint
you got some some salty dudes that might
tune in you know but you got dudes
that'd be like
okay what they doing over there mm-hmm
but they're gonna watch the jeff's show
that's when you drop that little gem of
something that
they can't get over there
you can't get a playstation fire a
little man is outside on the cheap give
them a reason to go out and splurge and
spend that money show them a little
something give them that aha moment
that the people that you see you're
preaching to the choir because the
people who's going to be there for the
xbox but these people ain't coming
across the street to see you they don't
care what you got going over there let
them see that your wheels is delicious
so
at this point you got the most eyes this
is the reason why that you show and
unveil your console on his platform this
is the reason why you show your games
and they best form on his platforms
because your people gonna go to your
spot and care about your stuff anyway
regardless you're not talking to them
they're you already got that money you
are trying to get these dudes that's
tuning in these 2.5 you want 2.5 you
want half of them to walk across the
street and be like that's right i can't
find a playstation anyway so i'm gonna
get this to hold me down and then
hopefully at this point they'd be like
you know what this joint been holding me
down since this drought
and this is dope though so
even even if they do got a playstation
and they're looking over give them a
reason to look over give them a reason
to tear down the plastic wall that
barrier that that box that they locked
theyself in give them a reason to see
because they're not going to your
channel
so if the analytics tell you they're not
caring about what you're showing world
premiere halo a significant update on
bethesda microsoft show they're like so
what mm-hmm but if you throw it on the
jeff show they'd be like man i gotta
watch this because they're gonna show
some playstation right
and this is what sticks in their head
this might get them to the store so i'm
down with showing everything over there
show all the stuff that you got over
this bust your guns over there cause
you're gonna bust your guns on this side
right and and save a little sprinkles
over here but if you got some big stuff
that you want to show show it on jeff's
stuff
get them over and then once you control
that narrative because you don't control
nothing right now playstation hasn't
dropped anything and he's still in the
headlines why because they control the
narrative they got people hungry make
them hungry fair enough no look i got
much too much to add everybody said most
of the points i was gonna say which is
yeah like you know
microsoft to me
was um
they've been this generation they've
been more
apt to put their stuff where a lot of
the eyes are you see them on twitch
you've seen them on the on the game
awards with the hellblade the console
debut that kind of stuff and they've
shown success so i think the pattern
will continue my question is
what does jeff get
right and the only thing where i do side
with attic even though i'm surprised
being very reasonable today i didn't
think i thought he would go harder on
this but i've always been i i feel like
you know i've always understood why they
do it it's just i would refer them build
their own to build their own no and i
get that and i just i i'm very curious
about star fields fate in presentation
how is it presented this is the big
creme de la creme triple a experience
you don't know experience from that from
the atm okay so they might do a story
trailer in the game place for their
stuff could be right it could be and um
i just want to see how that's presented
it's a big thing a lot of people want to
see the game play from star for that is
a coveted item from a media news piece
during this thing so i want to see how
that's handled and yeah it's to king's
point you know
as much as i know xbox fans may not like
it you know it's one of those things
where it's like look you have to go you
have to put something to him in an
audience that would never
go through xbox but i do understand at
its point which is
if you do intend to build your show you
got to build it so there it is catch 22
as far as what they want to do but i
think the analytics they've been showing
that they're gonna most likely give it
to them so we'll see i think they got so
much that it doesn't matter anymore like
they can do both you know what i mean
like because they got so much stuff that
they haven't even revealed to us yet i
agree
but at the same time i disagree because
they got so much
that they can do both it depends on what
they're citing and what they're doing on
the balancing scale if they're giving
all their good stuff to everyone else
and they're showing only stuff that
would be on an inside xbox yeah then i
would feel like that's the wrong step in
the wrong direction but if they got
multiple big things that they're just
letting him have one of the big things
right because they got the bigger stuff
then i could understand that
you know they they're working on a ton
of stuff but if a lot of that stuff if
the bulk of it isn't in a stage where
it's
naturally
showable yet something that you can
actually show people then that's a whole
different story it's like now like 60 of
the stuff that we're working on we can't
show yet right the other forty percent
how do we balance that forty percent
when we give the key leads to what we
hold back for our own show because we
got 90 minutes to show stuff like i mean
people not really trying to spend time
in that 90 minutes talking about game
pass or
to hearing about some new service no
they want to see games i love the
cadence that they did last year yeah
last year it was bold
yeah do that yeah
don't move off of that kind of kind of
uh
of direction that they went with it but
what you gotta have with that is actual
games to show yes absolutely no what if
they showed like indiana jones
right that would be a mistake because i
feel like that's that's a very coveted
product well that's the thing like
because it's such a well-known ip
already like it's such a popular brand
that it's going to catch people's
attention and make them well okay well i
want to play that right and
no matter where it's at right so that
might get people into the xbox ecosystem
by using an ip like that kind of like
when when a playstation had wolverine at
their show it's like man oh dude like
wolverine i gotta i gotta have a
playstation play that i think indiana
jones has the same effect and for the
people that already noticed the xbox
showcase notice where wolverine was
shown
on sony also it was a teaser trailer
which we already got from indiana jones
so at this point i don't want to see the
more teaser trailers from indiana jones
i've always seen the hat and the whip i
want to see
jones next time you see the game
perspective
you know slapping people
at that point i still can't get over
that indiana jones and and laura croft
collab that would be a crazy game yeah
what co-op or
i don't know i would prefer not to be
co-op but i would understand that they
made it co-op yeah that'd be crazy so
look that's all we got going to wrap up
long one today want to get these uh
super chats cued while i do the poll and
dance the poll is in with embracer group
acquiring crystal dynamics idols
montreal and square enix montreal
instead of microsoft do you think the
activision blizzard deal stops xbox from
attempting any more acquisitions the
choices are a no if there is a studio
publisher that microsoft is interested
in during this period they will still
make the move
b yes microsoft will not make any moves
to draw unnecessary attention to itself
due to the high-stakes nature of the
deal or c i don't care it's all fun and
games until my favorite studio gets
stashed up by the opps shoot to
everybody
right there to play the phones in the
chat see y'all up for the joint salute
to the man dallas's own lord mav aka the
fun speculation shadow absolutely
pleasure in the realm so much fun we can
talk gaming and trading games for damn
near
that was hilarious here your history
here on your journey brother where can
the fine people find you and what do you
have going on sir
i just got more content coming to the
channel uh it was just a blast guys
thanks to attic um
king david incognito and also slo-mo
it's good to see you man thanks for
hopping in here with me bro yeah fun
[ __ ] oh
yeah um but yeah if you want to find out
what we got going on easiest way is to
follow on twitter and fun speculation
i'm putting it in the chat right now go
ahead on youtube
type in www.all right
youtube got you mav i got you man
whatever we're gonna put it right
we got you slow you slow
now hit that notification bell on there
because you'll see when we go live
game streams we do uh multiple shows
like like cox said we got four podcasts
right so we got uh mondays is fun
speculation podcast where we have talk
about all platforms this non-console
centric on that show
uh we have a kind of an open panel a lot
of fun on that wednesdays is fun pop at
7 p.m eastern where we talk about marvel
dc star wars tv shows movies halo show
all that kind of stuff yeah it's an
absolute blast
and then also we thursday hong sol you
see them everywhere
my buddy and i uh have a two-man show
sometimes we have a guest on there but
we kind of dive deeper into topics right
when we get a chance to really get to
talk you know on pm and the pm and
that's mommy and kathy's song still move
broke from the am to the pm
and then on fridays is the show that
started it for our channel is xbox
ultimate podcast that is at 9pm eastern
time uh and that has a larger panel it
gets kind of crazy on that show
sometimes but you know we like to have a
lot of fun and just uh kind of keep it
positive and you know with a lot of
jokes and hanging out with the family
and stuff on there so i appreciate
everybody um check it out tomorrow night
again fsp if you haven't seen one of our
shows absolutely it's a little pong in
the chat repping pm to the pm i see him
we can get you the realm two pawn i know
i'm working i ain't forget you brothers
a lot of people i know i've got to catch
up behind but salute to everybody
fun speculation amazing and of course my
brother from the dps podcast might be
disowned by his partner on gaming forte
after his comments on fury but uh some
words for him
you know the status of that podcast my
[ __ ] everybody still can find slow mo
where else sir what else you got going
on
oh you know look first off thank you for
the invite of course it's always fun
when i get every time i come into the
realm i always seem to have fun i mean
you have to pay the boys
it's always a good time here i i always
enjoy it so again thank you you guys
make my sundays and then i i appreciate
that i don't forte i don't want to hear
that i don't want to hear that
you're trying to
[Laughter]
uh
yelling at each other every thursday
nights at 9 pm eastern that's damaged
for second podcast
last week's show we got a kind of little
facelift you know yeah
[Music]
everything you got copyright clank you
could use copyright oh no
no you got strike you got straight right
right thanks forte yeah yeah yeah
you got to strike
yeah we got no we got to claim that
that's right
i'm like somebody they want their money
they definitely want their
yeah come check out the show uh last
week was on my channel uh which i can
put in the chat yeah i already got you
on the twitter we're gonna do the
channel continue any particular reason
you don't have a dedicated channel to
that podcast oh lord
um also uh
i do lunch time with slo-mo
um
during the weekday okay usually around
like 11-1 whenever i can get time where
work isn't like hey slow mo save this
never
actually like you know play a game for a
couple hours to have some fun so i do
that too on the twix channel and you can
catch me by the same name
it's comment king leave my man though
it's coming there's reasons behind it
legit reasons it better show over and uh
grant the photo sixes there whatever
when you're looking for seven eight or
nine whatever one it better be there hey
man look i i i i imagine things will
change to the point where i'll be able
to do that
gta 6 ain't coming out into 20 30.
dude that it's the first guest
appearance though
happening
you and dealer yeah yeah oh god yes
be the same person
could you imagine if dealer was out here
and he's all these people he just got a
good control over his body refuses to
show their faces
yeah that's crazy i'm done continue slow
oh no that's it that's it i i appreciate
everybody
chad was fired that it was great no
doubt no doubt and of course actually
before we do that you got the chats
ready um oh yeah i'm gonna have to uh
i'll read these that's on my note and
then i'll go to them on okay let's get
it so we got a ten dollar supercharger
from situations jitsu sage
crystal dynamics is independent under
embrace or embrace their knowledge part
of their strategy is having internal
partners fund their studios game
xbox and cd can have multiple project
contracts
i would like to
if you pay the same price as everyone
else you should get the same content as
everyone else that's checks
made for them period
we got a free
got a a return from uh from gamer mcfly
he went to uh he he upgraded to awards
put the logo in there that's my logo i
got the new whip that's what i'm talking
about midway seven monster oh that's the
whole chat saying glad to catch the show
live great panel slo-mo and mav i'll get
back on destiny called that's right we
where you at bro
and i'm pulling up to the shop i'm
pulling up the shot so i'm gonna holler
at you let me know wasting time with
that oh my god oh my god that's why you
ain't getting your game in your intro
anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
so we got a fight out super from donald
damn you know it's bad when addict the
only one on the panel who did they reach
oh damn i get no okay dude okay
and then we got a 14 uh super trap from
fatigue fat fatigue yes
[Laughter]
even have got a free update after a game
pass
five dollars from dawn to taku what's
crazy is that
what's crazy is that getting the dlc to
run on switch would probably take more
time and effort to get it to running on
xbox i don't get it play
[Laughter]
the next time they release a game that's
what i'm saying why are you saying it
like he gonna pull up you'll remember
when they did that
like look if someone's not no if
someone's not respecting your money
they're giving it to everybody
then you don't have to respect a company
are you gonna buy their next game on
xbox no no
all right
[Music]
we need no video back to the suit
from uh amazing now hashtag bring back
no video out they like you more spicy
and they say when you ain't got your
video oh yeah
i had my camera on yeah you thought
about cheeks no it was funny people if
people noticed i had fury playing in the
background
[Music]
getting the best surprise just like he
got the x launch and hellblade that's
the way it needs to be
yeah it beats me because microsoft
doesn't need to convince the xbox loyal
it's the casual masses they need
there we go five dollars super chat for
mr two opinionated if i'm thinking that
like king that i would send a vowed or
some more hellblade to i can't that i uh
that
gameplay all right i'll do that we'll do
a balance off and on lord roughness five
pounds from chat stellar show by the way
guys i do believe xbox will save
surprise triple a for jeff show but
starfield better be on the xbox showcase
then we got 10
jd gamer kingly gets new big surprise
game reveals and three to four minute
star flight gameplay and ign gets five
to seven extended revealed developer
interviews followed by 20 to 30 minutes
after the xbox showcase no doubt and
then we got aurora wolf 2256. no you
missed one i missed on my daughter taco
i put a story trailer at the uh
keegley's that in with two into xbox
game showcase for gameplay i vowed and
hellblade two are my picks maybe show
off these partnerships too actually show
if you're gonna show anything microsoft
show that hellblade 2 gameplay
i mean like the combat gameplay yeah
yeah but i'm with you man we did kind of
see but anyway aurora wolf now is that
that next 22 56 okay 10 ounces of a chat
happy mother's day to all the gamer
gaming mamas out there like me salute to
the lady big tree in the building what
else you got got a five dollar super
drive from dj orr's hey bestie how many
hours how many more hours hey bestie the
show's over you ain't getting them
that's it five super chat from lord
roughness
i'll die on this hill forza motorsports
to shut to shadow draw uh drop day and
day out the xbox showcase i'm pretty
[Laughter]
but we don't want you to die there let's
get over this look at d.d lee a dj he
must be listening to some playstation
inside as you said yeah you know how
they did oh my god
coming out this year go away oh my god
you might
six hour show let's do it no we're not
doing let's stop listening
we gotta play some fury everybody enjoy
their sunday happy mother's day and all
that had a fantastic show we are out of
here peace
[Music]
24 hours
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do